[Music]
for those of you who don't know me I'm
bill Hecht I know most of you I'm a
member of the class of 61 and I'll
explain the red coat in a moment I would
like to say that the job of executive
vice president London Eye Association
has aged me so much that I deserve one
of these but not quite true many years
ago the class of 1924 elected me an
honorary member and unfortunately none
of the 30 survivors of that class are
with us today and therefore it's
incumbent upon me to represent that
class so I may be thus prayest member of
the 75th reunion class here although
when they're here I have to be very
careful they have been known to take me
to the faculty club and produce the fact
that they're much better survivors at
some things than I am we do okay
then I'm in real trouble because I'm
supposed to wear this coat with a
freshman tie all the time my principal
job is to introduce the president of MIT
but I wanted to tell you all that the
person who we owe a great debt to is not
with us today that's Phil sharp Phil as
you know is currently and soon to not be
chairman of the biology department here
at MIT a Nobel laureate and an
extraordinary man who called us several
months ago after actually helping us put
this program together and ask permission
not to be here because he's receiving an
honorary degree in Sweden and we gave
him permission not to be here the other
thing I want to say is that Bob Weinberg
a distinguished member of our faculty
fellow alumnus has a family issue and
will not be at the question and answer
period but will join us and speak as
well my job is really to call you to
order and introduce my favorite honorary
alumnus and his favorite bride is only
bride actually also not honorary alumna
and that's Chuck and Becky vest and
Chuck will introduce the morning program
let's welcome Chuck vest
[Applause]
well I'm not as fast on my feet as their
commencement speakers yesterday bill but
I have to tell you a funny story because
at lunch yesterday Tom and Ray my Otzi
click and clack our great commencement
speakers were there with all their
families and through the back end of the
room and their chairman alex d'arbeloff
was introducing people and he was of
course reading from a long list of their
family who were present with them and he
introduced Tom's wife and apparently
couldn't hear too well in the room
because when he introduced two women
stood up at the back and quite
appropriately clayed appropriately Alex
looked back and said Tom I don't
understand I announced your wife was
here and two women stood up what's going
on without a millisecond delay Tom said
the other two couldn't come today but
I've only got one I guaranteed but it
really is a great pleasure to welcome
you to what I know is going to be a
really extraordinary morning discussion
led by four really extraordinary people
whom I will introduce in just a few
moments but before doing so I want to
say that this really is a terrifically
exciting time at MIT and I hope you're
going to get a little sense of that
during your day or two with us here it's
exciting is measured by the achievement
of our undergraduates by the strength of
the new class that we have just admitted
could give you a whole lecture on that
and actually I'm going to but not this
morning the significant change and
growth of our physical campus I think
you're really going to be quite
astounded at what you're going to see is
literally a transformation in much of mi
t--'s campus over the coming decade the
continued diversification of our
educational and research agendas and
their focus on the future and our
interaction with the national and global
communities that we serve in so many
ways the academic year
that has just ended has been challenging
as always and yet very very fruitful
early in the spring for example we had
in a single 20 hour 24 hour period
visits to our campus by US Secretary of
Energy Bill Richardson Bill Gates and
Prime Minister Zhu Rongji of China in
many ways representing the breadth of
what we do here starting with
fundamental science because Bill
Richardson was here to visit the Bates
Laboratory Bill Gates of course
representing the future of computing and
the role of entrepreneurship in our
world today
and premiers you're on gee I think very
symbolic of the fact that MIT is deeply
engaged on a global scale and indeed
provides an important world platform for
leaders granted of course that the
roster of campus visitors in those two
days were a little bit more high-profile
than usual but frankly not by much I
could easily have cited any other month
in the past year to illustrate that 1999
MIT as it always has been is an exciting
and engaged institution during that same
month for example just a few of the
research accomplishments that were
announced I might point to professor
Alpha T Delta here in civil and
environmental engineering reported that
records the Nile rivers height can be
used to put recent occurrences of El
Nino into an interesting historical
perspective yet another contribution to
our understanding of the changes in
global weather patterns professor Maria
Zuber birth atmospheric and Planetary
Science and three of her MIT colleagues
were preparing to unveil a precise new
topographic map the surface of Mars that
you probably have seen in the newspapers
recently based on data obtained by
instruments aboard NASA's Mars Global
Surveyor spacecraft and at the Harvard
MIT division of Health Sciences and
Technology HST graduate student Jennifer
ELISA LSF reported that her
research team had developed an
injectable liquid cartilage that may
someday be used in a wide variety of
orthopedic and plastic surgical
procedures and therapies today's program
is going to focus on one of the most
important areas at MIT the interaction
of science engineering and medicine to
produce extraordinary advances in our
understanding of the human body
before we begin however I'd like to take
just a few moments to remind you that
this immensely valuable field of inquiry
is just one facet of the larger
scientific and engineering revolution
being played out here biology and
medicine are understandably a focus of a
great deal of our attention today and it
will be even more so as we go forward
but no one at MIT who has been at MIT
for long will will recognize immediately
that advances in these fields are
closely interrelated with advances
across a broad range of scientific and
technological disciplines all of which
interweave together so before we do
specifically into the worlds of
biotechnology medicine and healthcare
I'd like to take just a few moments to
give a slightly larger context of mi
t--'s current agenda as my colleagues
and I look to the world ahead I think
it's clear that the end of science is
nowhere in sight despite catchy book
titles of recent vintage we are under
the search for gravity waves we're
looking for antimatter galaxies we're
moving ahead in the exciting fields of
genomics and neuroscience and cognition
and learning quantum computing is
beginning to come onto the horizon here
at the Institute and I suggest you don't
really get me started on my excitement
about these and so many other things on
the horizon or we won't get to the main
program innovation looking forward
innovation and technology and business
and organization is clearly the key
theme of what is going to
be driving economies whether it be of
city-states regions nations the whole
globe new integrative approaches to
large complex systems and problems and
structures are going to have to be
developed to attack such serious
problems as global scale manufacturing
the issues of our global environment and
so forth research universities are
increasingly going to be just about the
only source of fundamental research and
scholarship in the United States that's
been our role for 40 years but folks
were pretty much the only game in town
today when it comes to truly basic
science a new paradigm of research
university is about to emerge and I
really believe that MIT is at the
cutting edge of this one that plays much
more importantly together as partners
with industry and with government to
work on these complex issues in an
objective and measured way of course
it's a future in which the ubiquitous
stent aeneas flow of information in
digital form is just permeating
everything the way we live the way we
work the way we learn the way we
entertain ourselves and that of course
is going to have profound effect on
education but nonetheless I deeply
believe as I believe as I know most of
my colleagues at MIT do that despite
this the residential campus experience
is still going to be the most important
way of educating the best and brightest
young men and women there's just nothing
that replaces this incredible magic and
synergy bringing these bright young 18
19 20 year-old people together to learn
in a very intense academic environment
the security and quality of our lives is
going to increasingly depend on building
a coherent productive society one formed
hopefully around common values yet one
that also revels in the rich diversity
of its membership we are going to need
to educate new leaders
with abilities values and desire to
apply the knowledge they they develop
here to apply it wisely and creatively
to the betterment of the human condition
so as we look forward we know that MIT
must continue to be a place that
attracts the best and brightest the best
and brightest students best and
brightest faculty the best and brightest
staff to assist them in doing their work
and carrying out their mission we must
be committed to excellence of course as
we always have been but MIT also must
distinguish itself by thriving on change
this is not an age in which staying
study staying still is going to be the
most important thing we must lead as
I've already said in developing these
new more integrative modes of
scholarship and learning and action
we must be even more adept than we
already are at bringing together
industry government and academia to
solve major problems facing the world
and in order to do all these things
we're absolutely convinced that we must
have a strong presence of an engagement
with the arts the humanities and the
social sciences we must expand our
technological and organizational
capabilities but also be very much
attuned and concerned about the moral
and ethical issues that the rapid
progress of technology and its effect on
our lives is going to have and finally
we continue to follow a very important
philosophy that says that MIT is first
and foremost an American institution
born and bred and developed here in the
United States and by the United States
but in order in the 21st century to be
the very best possible University
focused largely on science and
engineering and management we must be
engaged globally we must have a
cosmopolitan student body and faculty
and we must be engaged with our
colleagues around the
as always mi t--'s pursuit of this
vision will be able shaped and guided by
a brilliant and talented faculty and the
best way to demonstrate the continuing
excitement and rich promise of mi t--'s
future is just that to let the faculty
speak for themselves our four colleagues
who will lead this morning's discussion
are truly extraordinary in every
dimension in brilliance and
accomplishment and contribution to human
welfare as good and engaged people and
as teachers and mentors of the next
generation they really make us all proud
to be part of MIT now in order to move
forward efficiently I am simply going to
introduce all of our speakers now and
then turn the platform over to them to
guide the discussion for the rest of the
morning let me begin with Bob Langer
Robert s Langer jr. class of 1974 is a
kenneth j kermis house and professor of
chemical and biomedical engineering the
scope of Bob's interest and achievement
range is so widely that he is the only
active member of the US National
Academies of science and engineering and
the Institute of Medicine a pioneering
researcher in bio engineering techniques
his work has led directly to numerous
improvements in medical care including
the development of implantable polymer
wafers that release time controlled
doses of medication to treat tumors and
other localized illnesses
he is also successfully developed
artificial skin therapies to help burn
victims more recently he and MIT
colleagues professor Michael CIMA and
John Santini have announced the
development of a new microchip that can
be programmed to release specific doses
of multiple medications this so-called
pharmacy on a chip as a wide variety of
potential applications and has already
garnered considerable national and
international interest
Bob's work has already yielded some 350
patents and his extraordinary
productivity has earned him a level
lemelson-mit prize for excellence in
invention and innovation Bob Weinberg
Robert a Weinberg class of 1964 is the
Daniel K Ludwig professor of cancer
research at MIT it was a founding member
of the Whitehead Institute for
biomedical research a leading specialist
in the study of the genetic basis of
cancer
professor Weinberg has made a number of
major advances in understanding the
genetic mechanisms to control or inhibit
cell growth
Bob's internationally acclaimed work is
designed to lay the foundation for a new
generation of cancer therapies in the
evolving effort to understand and
control human cancer his discoveries
have marked a crucial watershed and
earned him an enduring place of honor
among cancer researchers he also has
received just received another enduring
place of honor here at MIT just three
weeks ago he received the Killian
faculty achievement award the highest
award bestowed by our faculty on one of
its colleagues and also if I might
editorialize a little bit something I
value very deeply about Bob is that he
does something that is incredibly
important he is a remarkable
communicator of the science of cancer to
the lay public something that I just
cannot overstate how important the kind
of writing he does for a morally
oriented audience is David page dr.
David C page is professor of biology
associate invest investigator at the
Howard Hughes Medical Institute and an
adjunct faculty member of the Harvard
MIT division of health science and
technology like Bob Weinberg David is
also a member of the Whitehead Institute
where he chairs the Task Force on
genetic testing privacy and public
policy as an advisor to numerous
governmental bodies he is one of
those rare and invaluable scientists who
combined first-rate research with
genuine public leadership on science
related policy issues his research is
focused on mapping the y chromosome as a
promising Avenue toward understanding
and treating a number of chromosome
based disorders including infertility in
recognition of his achievement in
biomedical science David received the
1997 Emory prize from the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences martha
constantine patent all of us at MIT are
absolutely delighted that the next
speaker in this sequence martha
constantine patent will be joining mi
t--'s biology faculty as of July 1st
she's one of the nation's leading
researchers and teachers in neuroscience
and has received among many other awards
and honors Matilde Soloway award in
neuroscience the Society of Neuroscience
Young Investigator award and as a John
Guggenheim has received a John Simon
Guggenheim Fellowship currently a
professor of molecular cellular and
developmental biology at Yale dr.
Constantine Patten has served as
director of Yale's interdepartmental
neuroscience training program under the
auspices of the National Institute of
Mental Health she has also served as
director of two different programs in
neuroscience training and behavioral
science and studies one at Yale and the
other at the Woods Hole Marine
Biological Laboratory we are honored
that she has been able to come up to
Cambridge to join us for tech day in
advance of her formal arrival on campus
so it's my pleasure now to simply turn
the stage over to my colleagues I'm
going to turn the stage over to Bob
Weinberg I just made a decision Bob come
on up
[Applause]
Thank You Chuck for that kind
introduction I'm most pleased and
flattered to be here on this occasion of
my own 35th reunion I've been here now
almost 40 years and I must say when I
first came biology was only a minor
variation on the MIT theme it was a
relatively minor part of mi t--'s
research and teaching agenda and it's
grown enormously since then to the
extent that the MIT Department of
Biology is now amongst the top 5 in this
country and likely in the world which is
an extraordinary testimonial to how
things change here in part in no small
part due to the farsightedness of some
of our leaders I think in fact that this
enormous expansion is due to two
separate factors first came the
discovery of the DNA double helix in
1953 by Watson and Crick Watson and
Crick are still around they're still
alive and kicking and and active in the
field of biology and I imagine two or
three hundred years from now one will
look back on this era in which we live
as having been as important in terms of
its watershed effects on science as was
for example the discovery of the laws of
physics by Isaac Newton three hundred
years ago so we live in an area an era
which really is epoch-making
in terms of the opening up the explosion
of a new field of science
I'm very impressed by the fact that we
live in this time of Watson Crick
although I must say most people are much
more impressed by the fact that all of
the work here at MIT goes on in the same
city as does the garage work of Tom and
Ray Malley Yahtzee click and clack the
tappet brothers that's for them
ultimately a more impressing fact in the
early 1960s there was the recruitment of
a large number of faculty to the biology
department and related areas and this is
resulted in this rich harvest of
research some of which I wish to discuss
now and by implication work of other
laboratories at MIT my focus this
morning is on how we have come to
understand the origin of human cancer
that is what provokes this disease and
what prospects does this give us in the
long run for under
and how to control it and in order to
elaborate on that theme I want to begin
by discussing one important lesson we've
learned and that lesson which has been
long in coming is that cancer is not an
inevitable consequence of the human
condition but rather that the incidence
of cancer occurs in vastly different
rates in different subpopulations of
humanity and in saying that I refer to
begin to the discovery in the in the end
of the 18th century by a London
physician that Chimney Sweeps
who had worked in their youth oh they
promised me up are we okay now is that
right
I was about to swallow it okay that man
who had worked as chimney sweeps in
their use in the London and the soot of
the London chimneys came down with
cancer of the scrotum at very high rates
and otherwise very rare kind of
malignancy the first insight the first
connection into the fact that a specific
exposure was connected with the onset of
a disease rather than this disease was
simply a spontaneous accident and over
the ensuing two hundred years the
evidence of connections between the
onsets of certain kinds of cancer and
exposures has accumulated largely
through the work of epidemiologists here
for example is the incidence of mouse of
a cancer of the mouth and throat among
women which we see is concentrated in
the southeastern party United States not
because of heredity but because as you
might speculate of the habit of chewing
tobacco in that sub population or for
example cancer the liver which occurs at
extraordinarily high rates in certain
parts of Africa and in Southeast Asia
but occurs relatively rarely thankfully
in this country a consequence one now
realizes years later of eating a tainted
grains and perhaps also of hepatitis B
virus infection other evidence from
epidemiology comes from studies of
lifestyle
example the description already in the
early 19th century that breast cancer
was a plague among the nunneries of
northern Italy this being do we now
realize in retrospect to the increased
risk of the disease due to the fact that
the nuns in the nunnery s-- obviously
bore no children and as a consequence
had a two to threefold increased risk of
breast cancer during their lifetimes and
then there are the discoveries of
Epidemiology here for example is the
risk of breast cancer in different
countries across the world and what we
see is an extraordinary variability from
one geographical location to another in
the risk of breast cancer as much as a
20-fold difference not a two-fold
difference or a 20% difference but at
2,000 percent difference across the
globe in the incidence of breast cancer
on this graph it's correlated on the
abscissa you remember what that is with
with a dietary fat intake some might
conclude that eating more fat gives you
more breast cancer but we will not leap
to that conclusion today I just want to
impress on you the fact that different
kinds of human cancer occur with
enormous ly different frequencies for
reasons that are not clear but one thing
is clear these differences are not due
to differences an inborn predisposition
that is to say in genetics because when
individuals move from countries of low
cancer incidents to countries of high
cancer incidents within a generation or
two their risk of cancer begins to
approach that of the people who've
always lived in that country so it's not
as if these people are genetically less
susceptible to this disease or for
example to prostate cancer which has a
remarkably similar kind of spectrum
prostate cancer until recently has been
as much as 7 fold more frequent in this
country than it has in Japan for example
and that's changing now due to changes
in Japanese diet again wish I wish you
to leave you with the impression that
the incidence of most kinds of disease
of cancer is highly variable and that to
the extent that we are susceptible to
these cancers in this country it's not
simply that we're doomed
we're preordained to come down with
cancer there are aspects of our diet and
our lifestyle and our
very largely diet and and lifestyle in
terms of smoking which influenced
enormous Lee disease incidents here you
can see yet another representation of
that here's the incidence of for example
among males of stomach cancer over the
last 60 years in this country and you
see it's gone down dramatically by
six-fold a testimonial to the powers of
food preservation the powers of
refrigerating food and the deleterious
effects at least as argued by some of
food preservatives which keeps foods
from growing moldy and their work
protects our stomachs so next time you
hear food preservatives maligned think
of this decrease in stomach cancer rates
over the last 60 years
here's another change in cancer
incidence this is the change in
incidence of course of lung cancer which
is by now the greatest killer in this
country at the beginning of this century
a case of lung cancer was so rare and
unique that it would be paraded in front
of a medical school class the professor
saying to the students that this was
such an interesting disease that they
likely would never again see another in
their lifetimes here is female cancer
incidence over the last 60 years and
these are all age adjusted incidents to
take into account the aging of the
population we see here that for example
stomach stomach cancer has gone down
dramatically cervical cancer has gone
down due to the Pap test lung cancer has
gone up and by now exceeds the rate of
death and women from breast cancer and
here's an amusing kind of curve the rate
of breast cancer mortality over the last
60 years among women age-adjusted has
changed absolutely not at all so the
next time you hear about a cancer
epidemic in this country remember that
if you subtract away the effects of
smoking and tobacco that the rates of
most kinds of cancer in this country of
either remain static or gone down there
is not we're not being overwhelmed by an
increased cancer risk and nor is there
any evidence that environmental
pollution causes any more than a minut
fraction of the tumors in this in this
population here's another way of
depicting the connection between diet
lifestyle and cancer here are the number
of deaths that are
every year in this country this was
several years ago from smoking the
effects probably a second-hand smoking
this is little uncertain here's the
number of deaths American deaths in all
of World War two or in Vietnam so the
annual death rate from smoking in this
country much of it due to a cancer not
all of it of course is absolutely
staggering
once again persuading us of something
that no longer requires us to be
persuaded of that is that that these
various kinds of cancers are not simply
a random breakdown of the human body
that their incidence is encouraged by
different different ways we treat our
bodies and that causes us now to focus
on the disease of cancer to try to
understand what it is biologically and
in so doing we go to a little bit of 701
a little bit of biology I don't mind
doing that since that's the way I earned
my living around here here's what a
normal tissue looks like we have we have
something like 30 trillion 3,000 billion
cells in our body here's a there's a
small slice of that and what we see if
we look in a normal tissue is that the
cells in a normal tissue are well
ordered that they form a very
exquisitely organized architecture and
that this architecture is disrupted when
a tumor arises in the body a tumor when
viewed microscopically is just seen as a
jumble of cells large numbers of cells
whose only objective in life is to make
more copies of themselves these cells
and the cancer are not interested in
creating finely-tuned architecture that
functions in one or another tissue the
cells in this tissue in this cancerous
tissue are only interested in
multiplying that is the only item on
their agenda and if we want to
understand how that happens we have to
understand that normal cells grow for a
certain finite number of doublings in a
normal tissue and then they stop growing
and cancer cells in stark contrast they
continue to multiply without limits and
ultimately yield so many descendants
that the mass of descendant cells
billions and hundreds of billions of
cells ultimately compromises one or
another vital organ in the human body
having said that I want to make one
other point about cancer we might
imagine there are normal cell
and there are cancer cells in the body
we might imagine that correctly and
having said that and looking at the
large mass of cells in a human tumor we
might ask how they arise and there in
fact are two countervailing theories as
to how they arise one theory says that
the all of the cells the tumor are the
descendants of a number of founder cells
each of which crossed the boundary from
normalcy to malignancy each of which
became independently transformed from a
normal cell into a cancer cell and once
transformed that cell began to multiply
exponentially yielding the large flock
of descendants cells mind you if you see
it a small human tumor the size of only
half an inch by half an inch that
already has a billion cells in it the
other theory the other model is that all
the cells the tumor are the descendants
of a single founding cell which begin to
began to multiply exponentially and it's
clear now from the detailed studies of
all the cells in a human tumor we now
realize that all the cells in a human
tumor descend from a single common
founding ancestor it is a so-called
monoclonal population of cells
Marnell chlorophylls are in a single
flock a single genetic ly descended
group of cells all deriving from a
common ancestor that crossed the
boundary from normalcy into malignancy
having said that one's attention is
focused on the behavior of that founding
cell trying to understand what causes it
now to behave abnormally and trying to
understand ultimately the environmental
factors that have driven or provoked
that conversion that transformation and
in so doing we focus on a single cell
this is what a single normal cell looks
like under the microscope and what we
want to do is to focus ultimately on the
nucleus of the cell this is what an
artist's depiction of a cell is and like
artist's depiction of almost everything
biological has not even a vague
connection with what a real cell looks
like but here here's the nucleus of the
cell and we want to explore the nucleus
of the cell because it's in the nucleus
of the cell at the heart and the mind of
the brain the heart in the mind of the
cell lie that's where the brains of the
cell are that's where the control
mechanisms are that tell the cell when
to grow or not to grow and thus we look
at the chromosomes within the human cell
in the nucleus of the human cell there
are 46 of them and they contain the
genetic information in the form of the
double helix ease of DNA discovered by
Watson and Crick that determine OTT only
how tall we are and what color our eyes
are but also instruct the individual
cell as to whether it should grow or not
grow in other words the individual cell
take takes it's instruction from the
genes that are carried in the
chromosomal DNA in the nucleus of the
cell we also want to focus on the fact
that the DNA is encodes information in
the form of sequences of bases here we
see them GAC t AG T and these sequences
of bases these DNA molecules like all
physical entities in the world are
subject to damage and thus when they are
damaged when a segment of DNA is cut out
or when the identity of one or another
base is changed for example going from
the C to a T or from going from a C to a
G then the information content of the
DNA sentence is changed in the same way
the dog and dig represent changes in
information content obviously in the
context of DNA we call these changes
mutations information has accumulated
over the last two decades that within
the DNA of cancer cells they're like
mutant genes and these mutant genes are
responsible for redirecting re or
castrating the behavior of the cell
forcing it to behave no longer like a
normal cell but rather like a cancer
cell and some of that information is
inspired by the work of a professor at
Berkeley Bruce Ames who began to
investigate the relationship in a number
of chemicals between their ability to
cause cancer and independent of that
their ability to damage the genes inside
cells
James was a proponent of the theory that
perhaps the way by which carcinogens
cancer-causing chemicals act is to enter
into the cells in the body damaged genes
and thereby trigger the outgrowth of
tumors and his research revealed the
following very provocative outcomes if
he studied the ability of various
chemicals to induce mutations in his
test these mutations being represented
here on the abscissa he could find some
chemicals which in this plotting were
very potent in their ability to cause
mutations to damage the DNA the double
helix ease of the DNA and conversely he
found other chemicals which were very
weak in their ability to damage DNA and
independent of these kinds of data these
results he plotted on the ordinate on
the vertical axis I know I don't have to
tell you that that the ability of these
various chemicals to induce tumors in
mice and rats so he compared the
mutagenicity the ability to damage DNA
with the tumorigenesis their ability to
damage to induce cancers and what he
discovered was that chemicals that were
extraordinarily potent in their ability
to induce cancer and lay on this end of
the ordinate were also extraordinarily
potent in their ability to induce
mutations and conversely chemicals oh
sorry wrong button after 40 years still
haven't learned and chemicals which are
very weak in their ability to induce
cancer are weak in their ability to
induce mutations and that had led to the
thinking that the way by which many
carcinogens act is that they enter into
cells in the body attack the chromosomal
DNA damage the sequence of bases in the
DNA thereby generating mutant genes
which once mutated then begin to release
instructions to the cell which drives
the cell into unrelenting cycles of
growth and division and replication and
one could test this kind of model
directly and experimentally in the
following way one can take DNA from
cancer cells so here we have cancer
cells growing in the petri dish the
model the theory were trying to test
here is the following
that was in the DNA of cancer cells
there lie mutant genes which are
responsible for the aberrant behavior of
these cells until now this has been a
speculation but here I'll show you in
that real experiment to prove it's true
so one takes Oh wrong button again
could we go there we go okay so one
takes cancer cells growing in the
Patricia and prepares their DNA and
these DNA molecules clearly contain the
genes of the cancer cell and then one
can take these DNA molecules from the
cancer cell and introduce them into
normal cells that are growing in the
petri dish here and ask the following
question if we put the genes of the
cancer cell into these normal cells will
these previously normal cells begin to
themselves behave like cancer cells all
that they've received are the genes from
the cancer cell and in fact such an
experiment succeeds because if one takes
genes and DNA from cancer cells puts it
into normal cells here some of these
normal cells previously normal cells
undergo a conversion a transformation
that enables them to grow now like
cancer cells here's what such a
experiment looks like under the
microscope oh this is not good there we
go okay here are some normal cells
growing under the petri dish and here
are the descendants of a normal cell
which acquired a gene from a cancer cell
called an oncogene a cancer-causing gene
and now these cells grow abnormally on
the petri dish and if one plucks these
cells out of the petri dish and injects
them into a young Mouse they'll start
growing into a tumor and such a simple
experiment proves unequivocally the
point that within the DNA within the
genes of a cancer cell they're like
cancer-causing genes oncogenes that can
drive normal cells into cycles of
malignant growth and thus the very
existence of these genes is no longer a
matter of speculation one can isolate
such genes using modern recombinant DNA
technology here's the way one would
depict such a gene as isolated by a DNA
cloning it's a single segment of DNA
it's six thousand bases long this is
only a minut fraction of the
total genetic complexity in a human cell
where there are three billion bases of
DNA and this gene is present both in
normal cells and in cancer cells but the
difference between this gene and normal
cells in cancer cells is that in cancer
cells this uncle gene in this case
retrieved from a human bladder carcinoma
has suffered damage the gene is six
thousand bases long and the essential
difference between the two genes is a
single one of these six thousand bases
as it's indicated here here's the
sequence of the basis of the normal gene
it goes GGC GCC GGC GGT and so forth and
in the cancer-causing gene retrieved by
gene cloning from the cancer cell and
sequenced the sequence has been
determined the ik so land exclusive
difference that converts a previously
normal growth regulating gene into a
cancer-causing gene is a single change
of the DNA base from a G to a T and I
this or I mention this to illustrate the
fact that the powers of modern molecular
biology can now detect with
extraordinarily precision and
specificity the molecular change is
inside cancer cells that are responsible
for their aberrant growth it's no longer
a matter of speculation that mutant
genes drive cancerous growth the mutant
form with a T here causes normal cells
to undergo malignant transformation the
normal gene which resides in all our
normal cells and has not suffered
mutation programs normal cell
proliferation and we know how such genes
work for example the normal gene and the
cancer-causing gene both encode the
structure of a protein as is the case
with all genes it's the protein that
does the dirty work of the gene and this
protein works as a molecular switch an
on/off switch which is continually
flipping back and forth when the cell
receives a growth stimulatory signal the
switch is turned on and when the cell is
no longer receives a signal the switch
is turned off and that's the way the
normal molecular switch works but in the
molecular switch that derives and is it
found in the cancer cell instead of
going from an on state to an off state
the molecular switch is left to run in
the on state for indefinite periods of
time being unable to shut itself off and
therefore a vital component of the
signalling circuitry of the cell which
normally should be on for a brief moment
in time releasing a pulse of growth
stimulatory signals into the cell is
left on at full blast for an extended
period of time driving incessant
unrelenting growth on the part of the
cancer cell we even know now by looking
into the innards of the cell on the
basis of work from hundreds of
laboratories about a complex circuitry
an inter relating cohort of proteins
within the cell here's the limiting
membrane of the cell and here are
proteins which talk to one another which
communicate with one another and process
growth stimulatory signals in the cell
helping the cell to decide whether or
not it should grow when one of these
proteins the one I showed you just
before which happens to be located right
here is disrupted through a mutation in
the gene that determines its structure
this circuitry malfunctions
so we now not only understand the
identities of many of the genes but we
begin to understand the inter
communicating proteins inside the cell
which operate much like components on us
in a circuit board mini computer inside
the cell which helps to determine
whether or not a cell grows and when the
components of the circuit board of the
mini computer are disrupted through
mutations of the gene that determine
their structure then the circuit as a
whole is disrupted and decision-making
goes awry here's yet another way of
depicting that and I'm not going to quiz
you on the details of this graph I only
mean to impress on you the notion that
we now begin to understand the innards
of the cell with great precision the
intercommunicating components which
enable cells to receive signals to
process these signals and to converge in
the normal cell on the decision as to
whether to grow or not grow not knowing
that one can begin to imagine how
disruption of one or another critical
component of this circuitry can then
lead to unrelenting growth we know as
well about yet other kinds of genes the
genes I talked about before are called
uncle genes and when they are present in
mutant form in the cell they drive
unrelenting growth they are in effect
operating like accelerator pedals in
in the normal cell the accelerator pedal
the normal proto-oncogene the normal
version of this gene stimulates growth
only briefly by being pushed down and
then flipping back up in the cancer cell
the oncogene the malfunctioning oncogene
operates like a stuck accelerator stuck
to the floor
driving unrelenting cell proliferation
driving the car to grow to move forward
without any limits there are yet other
genes which operate in an exactly
opposite or countervailing fashion in
the cell these other genes operate like
braking mechanisms like brake linings by
stopping cell proliferation and often
they're called growth suppressor genes
or tumor suppressor genes and we've
learned about these growth suppressor
genes by studying among other things a
rare eye tumor called retinoblastoma one
of the interesting things about cancer
research is that by studying tumors in
one organ one very often learns lessons
about cancers occurring all over many
other sites throughout the body so the
lessons about studying the rare eye
tumor retinal blastoma a tumor of young
kids up to the age of maybe five or six
seen in only one out of 20,000 children
is illustrative of principles that
govern the growth of cells throughout
the body in the case of the
retinoblastoma tumor we know that its
origin is due not to the hyper
activation of a growth-promoting gene
but on the contrary to the inactivation
of a growth suppressing gene and the
consequence is that a gene which is
normally a hundred and ninety thousand
bases long look at the line that's
labeled n here and goes from here all
the way over to here in many cancer
cells major parts of the gene are
missing they're eviscerated they're cut
out through mutations and as a
consequence this breaking mechanism that
operates to slow down cell proliferation
is disabled I mentioned that to indicate
that we now realize that in most cancer
cells there are at least two kinds of
genetic changes of mutant genes in the
cell which result in two distinct
changes in control one are the mutant
oncogene which drive unrelenting
proliferation like the stuck accelerator
pedal and the other are the defect
of tumor-suppressor genes which operate
like defective brake linings in the
cancer cell and therefore the forward
motion of the cancer cell in terms of
its proliferative power derives from
both of these things converging and
conspiring a stuck accelerator pedal and
a defective brake lining in this case
being disabled by mutations that destroy
the integrity of the gene that templates
the functioning of the braking mechanism
we also learn about these tumor
suppressor genes because when they are
inherited in mutant form in defective
form from one generation to the next
they are often responsible for heritable
kinds of breast cancer certain kinds of
eye cancer I'm sorry in this case and in
the case of other tumor suppressor genes
yet other kinds of human malignancies we
now believe that between five and ten
percent of human cancer is due to
inherited tendencies to one or another
kind of disease rather than accidents
occurring to one cells in one's genes in
one's lifetime some individuals between
five and ten percent of cancer patients
come down with cancer not because of the
way that they abuse the cells in their
body or because of bad luck occurring to
their cells and genes during their
lifetime but because they had the bad
luck of inheriting a defective gene from
one or another parent and in such
families one now sees the appearance of
cancers at high frequency here is a
retinal blastoma cancer family I
mentioned before that this cancer
otherwise only occurs in one out of
20,000 in the population and here you
see that Ana kindred in which the tumor
suppressor gene is inherited and passed
on from generation to generation in
defective form the cancer is seen in
very high rates and we know that similar
situations obtained in the case of
heritable colon cancer and heritable
breast cancer and a number of other
heritable tumors where a portion of the
tumor seen in the population are due to
in inborn susceptibility and finally I
mentioned one other recent discovery in
cancer research that has been most
exciting and provocative and that deals
with the ability of cancer cells to
proliferate without limits
what do I mean by that if one takes a
normal cell and puts that cell into a
petri dish and allows it to grow then
that normal cell will proliferate only
for a limited number of times in the
petri dish before stopping to grow if
one takes a cancer cell and puts it in a
petri dish the cancer cell will double
forever and that's really a provocative
finding because it suggests that the
normal cell has a built-in intrinsic
alarm clock that tells the cell it can
double for a certain number of times
before it must stop growing and the
cancer cell on the contrary has acquired
the ability to double without it without
limits the cancer cell is said to have
become immortalized not the human being
but the individual cancer cell because
it can continue to double forever which
apparently is an essential part of its
ability to form tumors and we now
realize the molecular nature of the
clocking mechanism that operates in
normal cells and inside cancer cells to
determine their replicative potential it
turns out that at the ends of
chromosomes there are DNA sequences that
are known as telomeres and we realize
that within normal cells these telomeres
grow increasingly short each time a cell
goes through a cycle of growth and
division and when they become critically
shortened these telomeres are no longer
able to protect the ends of their
chromosomes which is the normal role of
the telomeres they function in effect
like the little shields at the end of
our shoelaces to prevent the chromosomal
DNA from frame and when normal cells
grow through a go through increasing
cycles generations of doubling their
telomeres get shorter and shorter until
they finally have shortened so much that
they no longer able to protect the
chromosomal DNA the telomeres and the
chromosomes collapse and the cells die
cancer cells we've learned over the last
two or three years are able to forestall
and prevent this telomeric collapse by
developing an enzyme called telomerase
that is able to repair and elongate
these telomeres thereby disabling and
disrupting this generational clock that
prevents normal cells from growing
forever so II
here we've developed an increasing
molecular insight into the origins of
aberrant cancer cell growth here we see
the telomeres at the ends of chromosomes
here they're highlighted in yellow and
here we see a chromosome which has lost
its telomeres it has no yellow on the
end of it and this the cell carrying
this chromosome is soon going to die by
virtue of the fact that the telomere is
null is no longer here at the end of the
chromosome to protect the physical
integrity of the chromosome enabling the
cell to grow forever so having said all
that and wishing of course to talk much
more but not doing so because my time is
up
I mean to indicate to us that over the
last two decades to work in a large
number of laboratories we have now begun
to understand with increasing precision
the molecular abnormalities inside the
cancer cell they are no longer matters
of speculation twenty years ago the
mid-1970s if you ask the biologist
what's the matter with the cancer cell
why does it grow so abnormally he or she
would have shrugged the soldiers and
just said we really don't know but we
now know it is no longer a mystery it's
no longer a matter of speculation the
aberrant growth properties of cancer
cells have now been traced with great
precision to malfunctioning molecules
inside the cells to malfunctioning
proteins and these proteins have been
traced in turn to mutant genes which are
damaged in the chromosomes of the cancer
cell during the development of the tumor
or mutant genes that may be inherited in
mutant form and defective form from one
or another parent and this is most
exciting for those of us in cancer
research because it may lead to the
following in fact I believe it will lead
we have always done this work with the
notion with the faith that if we
understood the origin of the disease if
we understood the motive force behind
the aberrant growth of cancer cells we
would be placed in a very advantageous
position with respect to our ability to
develop in the future new kinds of cures
against the disease until now until very
recently to the extent that we had
therapies against tumor cells they
in the face of total ignorance of the
molecular aberrations inside the cancer
cell but all that has changed and not
changed
minimally it's changed dramatically and
so now I feel quite secure and confident
predicting in the next decade of the
coming millennium there are going to be
a whole series of dramatically new types
of anti-cancer therapies that are based
on this rich load of this treasure trove
of molecular information on the origins
of cancer that has been gathered in so
many different laboratories over the
last two and two and a half decades and
on that note I say thank you and happy
reunion as well to my classmates class
of 64
[Applause]
Thank You dr. Weinberg I have one quick
note if William Stewart is in the
audience could you meet me out in the
foyer in just a second we have an issue
with a kid not serious and now I'm
pleased to introduce Martha Constantine
Patton well thank you I should thank
Phil for inviting me to participate here
today in a little advance of my joining
this faculty it's actually fortuitous
that I follow Bob in this presentation
because he had a lot to do with my
coming here when I came up for a job
interview he took me to lunch and we sat
down and here is world-famous scientists
in cancer and he says to me in a decade
or maybe two decades we're going to
solve cancer this is a person in perhaps
the premier biology department in the
country and he said but we're not close
to solving the problems of the brain and
we want to get there and so we would
like you to come and join us and help us
that kind of an invitation is very very
hard for a neurobiologist to refuse I'm
going to talk to you today about
developmental plasticity I'm a biologist
who has followed neuroscience in biology
departments for over 23 years now and
biologists know about development
development has changed plasticity has
changed so what do we mean by
developmental plasticity well it's
simply the potential to change the
process of change and nowhere is this
potential more developed in organisms
than it is when we talk about the
development
of this organ that makes us us the
development of the human brain now brain
development involves genes involves more
genes than any other organ of the body
but it involves the genes to set the
pattern to set the molecules that
interact and then to open up that
pattern to interaction with the
environment so that the brains that we
use as adults today are the products of
our genes and the products of our
experience and when I talk about
developmental plasticity I talk about
how that final product comes about now
we know a lot about it empirically the
processes that change the brain are
iterative processes the the initial
experiences change the structure of the
brain that then changes the function of
the brain that then changes the way the
brain it responds to different stimuli
these processes are high occurring at
phenomenal rates in young children and
they are turned down slowly as we moved
sure actually there's a pretty big drop
at puberty okay young children are
phenomenal at the process of brain
change if adults these processes of
change are sequestered
to regions of our brain that are
involved in functions like learning and
memory it would not be good to have a
brain that can constantly change all its
circuitry and all its wiring throughout
our life but we have sequestered it into
select regions to allow us to be
learners and and adaptive throughout our
long lives now sometimes this process
goes Array children are born with
genetic effects defects that don't allow
their brains to interact normally with
the environment and sometimes perfectly
normal children
find up in what we like to think of in
broad terms as toxic environments
environments that are narrow or
restrictive for some reason and as this
brain plasticity is turned down some of
these effects get locked in and make for
maladaptive abnormal adult behavior and
so it's important for us to try to
understand these processes not only so
that we can change the environments in
which we raise our children but also so
that we can go in and as biologists and
technologists tinker with this mechanism
and perhaps reactivate it in regions of
the brain of the mature brain and thus
open up those regions to adaptive
plasticity later in life so I'm going to
talk I'm going to paint a picture with a
very broad brush today and give you a
sense of what this process of plasticity
involves and I'm going to talk a little
bit about mechanism a quite a quite a
focused approach to mechanism but
nevertheless one that will give you a
flavor of what drives those of us who
want to understand the biology of the
developing brain so here we go now well
developmental plasticity actually
operates at a number of different levels
there are instances if I've got this
loud enough in which a deprived early
environment leads to permanent
functional and impairment some of the
easiest instances of these for us to
understand and talk about are ones where
a sensory modality has been perturbed
early in development for example
children who are born with squint that
is in which one eye muscle is a little
loose so that the two eyes can't focus
at the same point in visual space these
children can never use their eyes
simultaneously and so the patterns of
activity that the eyes send into their
brain are never patterned in
I'm in an appropriate way and there's
cerebral cortex responds to that by
sequestering the inputs from the two
separate eyes two completely separate
populations of cells throughout the
circuits in the cortex and that
individual grows up never ever able to
have true binocular vision no depth
perception very severe problems in in in
things that we would consider completely
normal vision but there are much more
behaviorally severe consequences of
abnormal environments children in
orphanages that actually don't get the
normal stimulation during the first two
years of their lives these children can
be adopted brought in to wonderful
wonderful families and yet they still
have throughout their lives some
behavioral or impairments because of
these narrow deprived early environments
and those those instances we are far
from understanding the low sigh of those
changes we can understand the process
and I'll tell you some of the mechanisms
but we don't yet understand where in the
brain those disruptions have occurred
over the course of the last thirty years
we have learned that this brain
plasticity operates at the cellular
level to actually change the wiring of
the circuits that control and coordinate
our behavior that is genetics where's my
pointer here dictates particular source
neuron sending long processes to their
targets within the central nervous
system that's the product directly of
genes but the genes don't specify the
detail point-to-point ordering of the
synaptic inputs of these cells on to
their target cells that ordering is a
process of the impulse patterns of
activity that the young neurons carry
now in many instances this occurs
naturally and normally and we don't even
know it's happening
because some of this activity can be
spontaneous within the source pop
violation of neurons themselves but the
circuits become ordered they become
refined you go from for example a low
fidelity map of your retinal surface to
a high fidelity map of your retinal
surface as a result of the activity that
your retinal neurons carry into the
brain we now understand in this era of
molecular cloning many of the molecules
that are involved in this process that
is we understand them in terms of their
changes we can talk about molecules in
the early brain and molecules in the
late brain and we give them the same
name but they're not the same molecules
many of these molecules are made up of
multiple gene products we call them
subunits there are complexes of proteins
they sit on them on the membranes of our
neurons and yet their subunit
composition and many of the
modifications that occur to them change
over the course of development so they
are have the same label but they're not
doing exactly the same thing and so we
understand this in a very abstract way
and so the challenge for those of us
interested in the brain is to understand
how this is associated with this and
ultimately changes our behavior I'm
going to give you a few examples drawn
from the work of neurobiologists across
the country to just show you what kinds
of changes we know happen at the
cellular level what you're looking at
here is an image of a living brain in a
monkey actually this can now be done and
is being done for patients with epilepsy
in humans these are sophisticated
techniques for looking at detail changes
in the reflectance of neural tissue when
it's active when it's firing a lot of
action potentials a lot of electrical
potentials the reflectance of the tissue
changes and so if you have a very
sensitive photoreceptor or
ray and computers that can reconstruct
that pattern you can get an image of
activity patterns across the surface of
the brain and this is the small bit of a
surface of a monkey brain the monkey has
a little window secured into his skull
so he's sitting there he can actually
move around and with a photoreceptor
array above him these are the blood
vessels and what what what this monkey
is is being exposed to is a pattern of
light through only one eye he's wearing
the patch so what you're looking at is
the activity in his visual cortex
projected onto the surface of his visual
cortex from stimulating just his left
eye these dark stripes are the stripes
of inputs from just his left eye if you
took that patch off and put it on the
other eye
then you'd see these stripes get dark
you're looking at what we call the
ocular dominance columns in his cortex
we have them all by NOC Euler mammals
have them it is a way in which the brain
organizes the initial inputs from the
retina and it has to keep them very
organized because at the next level of
processing it takes some of this
activity and some of this activity and
it projects it to the cells that are
truly binocular well optometrists and
ophthalmologists have known for decades
that if somebody is born with a cataract
so if they don't have good vision in
both eyes that in fact just a few months
of experience with that cataract with
not not operating on that cataract can
result in essentially no vision in the
one eye and neuroscientists have
mimicked that put that condition by
raising monkeys for four weeks or so
that's all it takes with a defusing
prism on one eye of contact lens that
diffuses the image if you take that lens
off and then image what's going on in
this monkey's visual cortex you find the
this disruption this precise patterning
of activity of the inputs has been
severely disrupted severely abnormal and
it doesn't recover alright so this
animal exposed to this early in life
will never recover completely normal
vision if you did that to an adult
monkey no difference two weeks two
months six months you take the the lens
off and they're fine so the early brain
is is responsive to the environment and
abnormal patterns of activity can become
locked in to that early brain another
example and one in which the the range
of adaptive human behavior is really
exemplified is is been documented in
native speakers of American Sign
Language people born deaf who grow up
using American Sign Language as their
native language this is a highly visual
very motion sensitive language in which
emotion and meaning are conveyed not
only by signs but by the motion of signs
we've known for a long time that these
people are exquisitely sensitive to
motion much more so than those of us who
have normal hearing these are fast
magnetic resonance images of the brain
of a hearing person an adult hearing
person and an individual who learned
American Sign Language as a child these
people are in a scanner and they are
being stimulated with a moving visual
stimulus what you see this is this is
actually the same brain here we're
looking at it this is the front this is
the back this is the visual cortex and
now you're looking down at it from the
top again in the visual cortex in the
the hearing the normal person as would
be true in in our brains all
those who are true hearing individuals
that visual stimulus activates this
visual region of our brain but in the
native speaker of American Sign Language
that same stimulus now produces
activation in wide regions of the visual
of the cerebral cortex not only the
visual regions but auditory regions and
some regions of the frontal the
association cortex this brain is
permanently changed but if an individual
learns American Sign Language after four
years of age you don't see this pattern
okay these are changes that our brains
are capable of early in life and after
that that potential is lost very
adaptive changes all right well how do
you study this how do you really
understand what's going on
mechanistically and this is where the
experimental approach that utilizes
animal behavior physiology and whenever
possible molecular biology comes into
play and I want to tell you about one
particular set of experiments because
they illustrate the range of these
techniques this is a barn owl these this
has work done by a good friend of mine
Eric Knudsen who happens to be at one of
those small universities at on the west
coast but anyway barn owls hunt at night
and they hunt for small prey objects
with incredible exquisite localization
and they can use vision so they if they
can see it they'll use vision but they
can also hunt in complete darkness so
they can localize prey objects
exquisitely with both the auditory and
the visual modality and and this is this
happens to be Roger the owl
and with a time-lapse showing how he
hones in on this
my house now what Eric and his
colleagues have done is is used this
behavior of the owl to understand how
the brain coordinates this visual and
auditory information to orchestrate a
precise motor pattern of precise
behavior and the experiment is to take
young owls and train them to hunt for
mice or actually to to dive at a point
on the floor for which they get a reward
okay and you can make small sounds at
that point and in a normal hour ow he
can do that behavior perfectly well
whether it's a visual stimulus or an
auditory stimulus that he's homing in on
that reflects registration of the maps
of auditory space and visual space
within the Owls brain and in fact within
our brain we can do it we're not as good
at it as owls but we can do something
very similar Eric then fitted these
little young owls again a major point
here these have to be young owls with
prisms that deflected the visual image
so now what he has done is he has
dislocated the visual image from the
auditory stimulus and at first the young
owl doesn't do a very good job at
localizing things he's getting disparate
stimuli but if you allow him to fly
around in these big aviaries he will
eventually get very good at localizing
prey through either modality and you
look in his brain and what you have
discovered is that the auditory and the
visual map have come in to register what
has happened is that the neural
mechanisms of plasticity have brought
the auditory map into register with
the displaced visual map of space okay
now you can take off the prism okay a
young owl can go back and behave quite
normally you can measure in this
experimental animal how good that animal
is at adjusting by looking at how
displaced his behavior is when he's got
the prism on and what you discover well
we can make you displace here I don't I
thank you that's a little bit easier
okay thank you this this is a measure of
the the behavioral shift the owl is
capable of doing with the prisms on and
you discover that young owls can shift
their behavior quite dramatically with
the prisms so the ability to shift is
very high however a young owl given and
this is only about a week and a half of
experience that the animal needs so you
place the prisms on these owls at
different times during during their
their juvenile period and in fact you
discover that as you place them on older
and older owls the ability to shift to
adjust has gone down okay so that an
adult
owl can wear prisms for for a year or
two and providing he doesn't hurt
himself by getting confused in his
aviary he you can test him and he has
never adjusted all right
well what's going on at the cellular
level actually there's remarkable
agreement does that mean something I
should worry about okay I see it's not a
strange fire alarm or something else
all right the rule is a very simple one
okay and and it's one that almost
everybody in in this field agrees on and
that is that simply each young neuron in
the in our central nervous system in our
brain follows a very simple rule during
the course of its development it has the
opportunity to accept inputs from a
variety of different source nons and it
retained only those inputs that are
effective in firing it in driving it in
activating it and there's a very simple
phrase that that is is remarkably easy
to remember neurons that fire together
this this this and this wire together
whereas those guys that don't fire
together get lost during development
young projections are remarkably
exuberant there are many more
connections that are made in the early
brain that are ever retained into the in
the adult and the rule for which ones
are retained or that you retain the ones
that are effective and the patterns of
activity that they carry determine who
is going to be effective because if this
guy and this guy and this guy are active
together their drive will some on the
target and fire that neuron and there is
a mechanism that many of us are actively
at work on that feeds back onto these
inputs and stabilizes them into maturity
now the various maps of our sensory
referral fields refine during our
development using this rule the inputs
are initially disorganized
we know that neighbors within the source
populate
of neurons 10 in a probabilistic sense
to fire together so that of the norm
enormous number of connections they can
make the ones that they actually
continue to retain and do make are those
that come from source neurons that tend
to be active together they refine into a
relatively nice point-to-point
projection because they use this pattern
of activity temporal pattern of activity
a very dynamic property this is actually
an example that I pulled out of an old
file because I think it illustrates how
this happens without us being
consciously aware of it a number of
years ago a student of mine who's now
actually a professor at NYU performed an
experiment in which he raised young mice
with a click all right if you have a
good amplifier what the click does is it
drives all the neurons within a quite a
broad frequency range coming from your
ear together all right
so instead of when you're just sitting
listening say just to white noise it
sounds like nothing to you but in fact
what your central nervous system is
seeing is a lot of different frequencies
altogether like white light white light
is all different electromagnetic
frequencies together
noise is frequencies auditory
frequencies played together now during
normal development in mice if you look
at the sensitivity of cells in the
central nervous system we they have what
we call very broad tuning curves that is
all neurons will have a frequency to
which they are sensitive at very low
intensities but then as you get further
away from that frequency the cells are
much much less likely to respond to a
low intensity and so this is a tuning
curve adult organisms
all vertebrate species or the vast
majority of vertebrate species have very
narrowly tuned tuning curves but young
organisms have broad tuning curves when
Dan raised these mice in this click
environment he discovered that this
normal process of going from very broad
tuning curves to very narrow tuning
curves had basically been stalled in the
range in which the click was giving
equal input across the frequencies so
the auditory nerves were now not giving
information about who was who's nearest
neighbor right instead over a broad
swatch of neurons they were firing
together and the process had been jammed
so the cells didn't lose frequencies
inputs from frequencies that were quite
disparate instead they retained many of
them and in fact these animals have very
poor frequency discrimination okay so
the bottom line is the reason the Bach
family might all be great composers may
be partly genetics but partly because
early on they heard a lot of very nice
music
all right so so so who are the molecular
players in this game
the molecular players are the molecules
that mediate the communication between
input neurons and their targets these
are the neurotransmitters and the
neurotransmitter receptors
neurotransmitters are very simple
molecules and in fact the major
neurotransmitter in our brain is the
very simple molecule molecule glutamate
but there are close to now 30 different
defined glutamate receptors on our
neurons and we now know that one
particular category of glutamate
receptor is very very important for the
early development and early operation of
this plasticity mechanism I thought I'd
show you a picture of a real neuron
instead of a cartoon this is one growing
in culture and all these little dots are
fluorescently tagged glutamate receptors
so there are a lot of them on our
neurons the one I want to call your
attention to is one that is known in
mnemonic Lee as the NMDA receptor the
n-methyl-d-aspartate receptor it's
called that because nm and Methodius
part eight is an exogenous molecule that
happens to bind with very high affinity
to this receptor and it's very useful
pharmacologically for studying this
receptor but it's unusual in that this
receptor is very very exquisitely tuned
to respond when there's a lot of input
activity coming in simultaneously to a
neuronal membrane alright and it lets in
a lot of a very important ion calcium
and we don't begin to understand all of
the biochemical cascades that this
calcium mediates but we do understand
that this molecule is
disrupted in the early brain disrupts
many of the refinement processes that
I've been telling you about and this is
an example from a study that we and
saidif collaborators did a number of
years ago this is a rat brain and this
is a midbrain visual region of a young
rat and what we've done here is labeled
the population of processes that come
from just the posterior pole of this
young rats retina these these processes
are labeled with a fluorescent dye and
you can see that on postnatal day four
they go all throughout this region they
terminate throughout this region by day
six they are beginning to show a very
specific region of projection although
there are a lot of processes in abnormal
regions by day twelve they're restricted
to one one region of this of this visual
structure in the central nervous system
that is very characteristic of the adult
now this is happening on all points of
the retina so very early in life this
visual map is very diffuse very
disorganized and it refines we can go in
and block this n-methyl-d-aspartate
subtype of glutamate receptor actually
we block it with a polymer that Bob
Langer developed and you'll be hearing
about shortly and you can put in the
this polymer and infuse it with an
antagonist to this receptor and when you
do that you discover that these are
young rats which can't use their NMDA
receptor retain a lot of these exuberant
projections so the refinement process is
blocked when this receptor is blocked
I'm not going to go into a lot of
details and I'm going to stop very
shortly but what I want to emphasize is
that we now know that simply blocking
this receptor not only blocks the
development and
I meant of many sensory maps but it
blocks the realignment of auditory and
visual maps in the owl and it blocks
many of the activity dependent changes
in visual cortex this is a very
important molecule it's certainly not
the only player in this game but it's an
important molecule so what can we do
with this information
how does it help us to understand the
process and hopefully to manipulate it
for the better of humanity well in
mature brains the function of this
receptor is low and in fact it's low and
lowest in those regions where the
potential for adaptive neuroplasticity
is low all right and in fact it changes
its sensitivity quite abruptly in many
regions of the brain and one can then
say well can we understand what changes
that sensitivity can we reactivate
developmental plasticity in a relatively
mature brain and allow for recovery from
early deprivation or many instances of
CNS trauma where you might want to
recover normal wiring or in fact help
children and young adults recover from
early neurological dysfunction well
we're now learning a lot about the
changes that happen in this receptor we
know that there are mature type subunits
that get added to this receptor as the
brain matures you take out baby subunits
you activate new genes you plug their
plot their products into into the
receptor and that changes the function
of the receptor we also know that there
are modifications that that occurred at
discrete times and development to this
receptor sitting on already established
neurons and we're learning what those
molecules are and we're learning how to
manipulate their function so indeed
there is a great potential for designing
drug
that can target those enzymes that alter
the function of the receptor and we can
also reintroduce the baby genes into
regions of the mature brain and those
will allow us to reactivate the function
of this molecule in a mature brain but
there's a catch here all right
we have to know what brain region to
target to okay
you can't just reactivate this receptor
throughout the brain because indeed if
you if you over activate the receptor
you can cause brain cell death all right
so we have to know what regions we need
to reactivate it in and we have to know
the Cascades within the cell that
activate the cell death process I mean
this receptor is also a major player in
the death of cells after brain talk
trauma so you would like to turn it off
when you don't need it you want to turn
it down okay so we can answer those
questions maybe in 20 30 or 40 years
okay but I want to add one last thing
and then I'll get down from this pulpit
this is that these are data from the
owls again okay and what this data is is
showing you are the results of
experiments in mature owls all right
so Eric takes these animals raises them
some have prism experience early some
are raised it's just normal
owls and he discovers that an owl that
has never experienced a prism can never
reach us okay
never readjust its behavior however the
owls that had maybe just two or three
weeks of prison experience as juveniles
quite rapidly learn to cope with the
prisms again you have introduced into
these owl
nervous system a plasticity that isn't
normally there by giving it a broad wide
experience as a juvenile and I think
quite apart from molecular biology and
biotechnology there's a lesson here for
educators and sociologists as well broad
experience in early childhood when the
brain is plastic will provide a
potential in adulthood for tremendous
plasticity that I think many of us have
just never tapped thanks
it's nice to see here our next speaker
will be Bob Langer and Bob is going to
shift Bob is an engineer some would say
a consummate engineer and I don't I've
heard had the privilege of hearing Bob
several times this year and I'm always
amazed Robert thank you very much it's a
pleasure to be able to speak to you
today I guess we're going to shift from
really good biology to now engineering
and my background is that of a chemical
engineer and what I'd like to discuss
with you is the area of biomaterials and
I'd like to give you a talk at least to
give you a little bit of my view of the
future of how biomaterials may affect
our lives I'd like to focus in on two
ways that will maybe see this one is
ways of delivering drugs better and the
other is the idea of creating brand-new
tissues in the human body so let me
start with an example of what's already
happening and then take you through some
of the work we've been doing in both of
these areas this is an example of a
polymer based system to deliver a drug
it's a nitroglycerin patch people may
have seen these people may even use
these but this field of what we call
controlled drug delivery which involves
putting drugs in plastics and delivering
them over long times at steady rates is
a very new field if you just went 20
years ago there would be none of these
on the market today we see this to be a
thriving field last year for example in
the United States there were 16 billion
dollars of sales of these kinds of
systems not just this one but all
different types and it's not only that
you can just prolong delivery you can
tremendously reduce the side effects
associated with conventional drug
delivery why is that important well let
me just give you a couple statistics
last year in the United States over a
hundred thousand people died taking
prescription drugs exactly the way they
supposed to that's four times the number
of deaths caused by AIDS in this country
last year if you look at the health care
cost associated with people taking drugs
exactly the way they are supposed to you
know with mishaps it's a hundred and
thirty six billion dollars that's more
than heart disease in the United States
so these are huge problems if you could
deliver the drugs at steady rates rather
than the peaks and valleys which you
normally get when you take drugs a
conventional way the peaks potentially
causing toxicity
the valleys basically being ineffective
there's the potential to eliminate many
side effects caused by conventional drug
therapy this is just one example which
can prevent problems associated with
liver damage and so forth but not only
can you use a technologies like this to
deliver drugs for one day you can use
technologies like this this is a little
implant placed underneath the skin
called the Norplant
it's incredibly powerful technology and
can deliver a drug with a single implant
for over 2,000 days or five years this
is a system as I said called the Noor
plan I'm not sure what the background is
anyway let me tell you a little bit
about some of the things that we've been
trying to do without us a little bit of
background the molecules that are being
delivered here and and this is also a
very new system first approved by the
FDA in 1991 therefore very very tiny
molecules what I became interested in
going back to the early 1970s is could
you deliver large molecules polypeptides
peptides and so forth these molecules
are incredibly difficult to deliver
they're very hard to swallow because
they get destroyed they don't get
absorbed they're very hard to take by
these patches for the same reason if you
inject them you're often faced with very
short lifetimes in the human body so if
you want to use these on a chronic basis
it would be critical to have a way to
deliver them in an unaltered form and
yet protect them from harm but when we
started our research
it's a projector
wonder if somebody could help me this
doesn't seem to be working too well
thank you so when we started our
research the conventional wisdom in the
polymer field was you would not be able
to use these kinds of approaches to use
polymers to slowly deliver big molecules
if you look in the literature in the
1970s you often see quotes like this so
the direct quote I'll just read you this
one it says the agent to be released as
a small molecule with a molecular weight
no larger than a few hundred one would
not expect that macro molecules for
example proteins could be released
because of their extremely small
permeation rates through polymers
actually this quote was very helpful to
us and getting a number of patents in
this field and it was against this
background that we started this work
what did people think well the people
thought at this time is that if you had
a big molecule you know and you're
trying to move through a polymer it's
kind of like diffusing through a brick
wall alternatively you might have you
know delivered go through like something
like Swiss cheese
but that's you know with big pores but
that's gonna be really fast so the
question was how could we get released
but do it slowly so we spent several
years I don't think this is working
maybe somebody could control the slides
if I just say next slide so we spent
several years we were able to make
little microspheres like this here's one
cut in half next slide and if you did a
release curve what we'd see is that you
could get different take different
proteins this is 14,000 this is quarter
of a million these are in between you
could get released for over a hundred
days and using various engineering
approaches next slide you could get a
constant release for really any rate of
time that you wanted now the question is
how does this work and you know I'll
just tell you a little story you know
when I started my work I was a postdoc
at that Children's Hospital in Boston
and I'd never given a talk at a meeting
before
so in 1976 I was asked to give the very
first talk that I was going to give this
was at a big polymer meeting in Midland
Michigan Midland as you may know is
where Dow and Dow Corning is and a big
polymer Center so I you know stopped
work about three weeks in advance of
this talk and I kept practicing my talk
into a tape recorder was before
VCRs were available and I kept doing it
over and over because I was really
nervous and I was you know pretty young
at the time and so when I gave the talk
and I actually felt I did okay I didn't
forget too much of what I intended to
say or anything like that so when I get
done with the talk I felt you know there
were all these you know more elder
polymer engineers and chemists some
pretty famous people in the audience and
I was this young guy and so I thought
when I was done and I did okay that you
know these scientists being nice people
would want to encourage me this young
guy and so when I got done a number of
them came up to me and they said we
don't believe anything you just said
[Laughter]
that was kind of my introduction now
scientists treat other scientists I keep
seeing that unfortunately not form MIT
graduates but so it wasn't till about
three years later 1979 that that several
groups had repeated what we'd done and
then the question shifted to how could
this possibly happen so what we did a
next slide next slide is we use
techniques that are normally used in
medicine medicine pathology and we made
cut very tiny thin sections through
these polymers one of them we use was
ethylene vinyl acetate copolymer and we
cut a thin section through it and here
is a 5 micron thin section there's no
drug in it and actually if you did a
permeability study what you'd find is if
the molecules were 300 molecular weight
or greater they they would not be able
to diffuse from one side of this very
thin membrane to the other so how could
this happen how do we get these
molecules out well the next slide what
we say is that if we put a protein in
and now we put a red protein in
myoglobin we get what we call a phase
separate
raishin polymer is white protein is red
this is before any release has taken
place but if we release these systems
for say a year and then cut a thin
section the next slide shows that left
behind after the release our pores
notice how different this slide is and
the one you saw two slides ago so these
pores are made by the way we incorporate
the drug and and and be end by and what
you can see is when you look at them
that the pores can be significant in
size but also we've done a lot more
microscopy and what you can see is these
pores have very tight constrictions
between them kind of like going through
Logan tunnel and they're incredibly
winding and tortuous in fact one of the
analogies I use when I go different
places to explain this to people why
this works is I tell them myself being
from Massachusetts you can kind of think
of this is like driving a car through
Boston and by controlling the poorest of
my students over the years and there's a
number of engineering approaches we've
learned to do this by controlling the
pore structures we can take very tiny
systems we can make them last anywhere
from a day to actually over three years
in fact the biggest problem I've had as
a professor and getting really long term
release has actually not been the design
of the system it's absolutely been my
ability to find a graduate student who
would do the experiment that long and
actually I was very very fortunate in
the late 1980s I had a terrific graduate
student named Marc Saltzman and Marc
actually did this experiment kept
releasing it releasing it he did it for
three years and two months and then one
day he came up to me and he said Bob you
know I've been thinking he was doing
this for his PhD thesis he said Bob I've
been thinking what will I do if this
experiment now fails he said do I have
to repeat it
and so we stopped that three years two
months and five days but but I would
like to think with the right graduate
student we could go five six seven years
I'm not we haven't found them yet though
but anyhow that marks actually doing
very well he graduate he's now a full
professor at Cornell so there's good
endings to these stories at any rate
what could you use these for well one
type of thing you could use these for is
really in what we call bio essays for
the type of very elegant studies you
just heard in in the last talk and
that's been one good example and there a
variety of different bio assets for
delivering what we call informational
molecules for just understanding things
in biology better but in addition to
that there's potential clinical
applications the next slide shows you
one that Larry Brown one of our students
worked on and that was taking an aspirin
sized pellet with and using it to slowly
deliver insulin this is still in animal
trials for over a hundred days with a
single little implant and these actually
have been used clinically these
principles the next slide shows you an
example we had a group of Japanese
scientists coming every year to our lab
in the 1980s and this is a Takeda and
they work with abbott and they came up
by using these principles to make little
micro capsules very much what I just
showed you but they put it in this
little bottle like this this is called
the Lupron depo and this system takes a
peptide that's about 1,200 molecular
weight it's actually one of about three
systems that does this it's about 1,200
molecular weight you put in these little
polymers it will slowly deliver this
drug for four months you absolutely
lutely need to put it in the polymer if
you didn't it would be destroyed right
away when it's injected in the body and
it's so big you need to inject it you
can't swallow it this today is the most
widely used way of treating advanced
prostate cancer endometriosis and
precocious puberty there are a number of
other these of these on the market and I
think what we're going to see as we
moved into the next century are many
examples of these probably the very next
one will be a one-month delivery system
developed by Alchemy's a local company
and genatech for delivering human growth
hormone which now little children have
to take once a day pretty soon they'll
be taking it once a month but there are
many other examples I believe will
so see using these kinds of approaches
but I'd like to think that this is just
the tip of the iceberg
even though I've shown you that we can
deliver drugs at steady rates or
decreasing rates
wouldn't it be nice someday in the
future to be able to really regulate and
control what you do so a few years ago
next slide we had this idea could we
actually make smart systems and the
first way we thought about doing this
was with magnets and our idea was to
take an elastic plastic put little
magnetic beads in it this is a cartoon
not drawn to scale and then put drug in
it which are represented by these little
dots and our thinking was is that under
passive conditions the drug would
diffuse out but when but when will we
apply an oscillating magnetic field kind
of squeeze it the beads kind of squeeze
these pores so a lot more drug comes out
and the idea is almost like milking a
cow I'm sorry do you
it wasn't working wasn't working too
well so anyhow I just want to make sure
everybody here was working you know it's
that so the idea would be if you'd
almost do like milking a cow and squeeze
a more drug out of the pores the next
slide just shows a picture of what these
look like here's an example of one
here's an x-ray showing you the magnetic
beads now you might think how would how
could you get how would you get these to
work someday practically so our idea is
we make a little implant maybe in the
wrist area and then maybe we give
somebody a special wrist watch like
device that you could have
pre-programmed or you could turn it on
say near mealtime now we weren't able to
do this right away but I mentioned this
to one of my very good graduate students
at the time Elessar Edelman alliser's
this was in the early 80s and losers now
a professor at MIT also but and I said
to him could you try to make a rotating
system you know something to simulate a
wristwatch but of course we did weren't
able to miniaturize it right away
but what I wanted is something that
would rotate around to create an
oscillating magnetic field the problem
was this was very early in my career and
I didn't have much research money and so
and eleazar was very ambitious student
and so I said Eleazar could you try to
make something that would rotate around
to test this out but I said could you do
it for less than $50 so next slide so
what he did he went home and he actually
had a record player a Victrola that he'd
had since he was a small boy he took it
apart and he made this system here's the
record player motor he actually made
this by the way for $49.50 so here
here's the record player motor he
attached it to two Plexiglas disks the
top is stationary and has vials and the
bottom one will actually have magnets on
him here you can see one and it will
rotate around to create this oscillating
field then it rotates like at 33 or 45
or 78 rpm the next slide shows you what
it looks like in the lab vials magnet
and what you see on the next slide next
slide is that when you turn on the
oscillating magnetic field you can get
released
it's up to 30 times what you get when
it's off and the height of these Peaks
can be controlled by the strength and
the frequency of the magnetic field
now we also wanted to test you know you
always want to test these things at
least in animals if not people
so in animals what we want to do is
again take diabetes as an example the
next slide shows of what we did we took
a little system here this has about a
two year supply of insulin for a rat to
give you an idea how small it is we put
it next to a ping-pong ball and a ruler
and then what we did is we place this
underneath the skin of rats but we had
to change our triggering device a little
bit for these rats next slide here you
say it and you you can see that these
rats are really very very happy if this
is the treated group controls I won't
tell you about but at any rate we gave
him 20 minutes treatment to the field by
the way sometimes people think when they
see this that we're rotating the rats
but but they're not remember the rats
are in the top part that stationer is
the bottom part that rotates around so
we give them 20 minutes treatment with
the oscillating field the next slide
shows you the results and diabetic
levels about 400 this line is the time
of implantation the blue bar show you
passive delivery of insulin the red bars
show you what you get just 20 minutes
later and each time you get a
significant lowering so this shows you
you get a response in vivo in 20 minutes
we're still not doing it on people yet
but we hoped at some point to be able to
do that but we have as have other people
worked on new ideas hopefully even
better ideas for getting smart systems
I'd like to tell you the latest and the
latest idea we had is a few years ago I
had this idea I was watching a TV show
that talked about Intel you know the
company that makes chips and I thought
you know most people when they look at
about things on chips they think of
computers and stuff I always tend to
think about drug delivery because that's
what we do so I thought gee wouldn't it
be interesting if we could turn chips
into drug delivery systems so the next
slide shows you our idea and I did this
I called up Michael CIMA who's a
professor in material science and I got
a John Santini a terrific
graduation to work on this and our idea
is what if we took a silicon wafer this
is just a prototype by the way and we
build little wells in it and we could
basically build in a little wafer here
we just did three but we could actually
do a thousand it's actually very easy to
do and the idea is actually kind of
simple on one side of the chip we have
an impermeable epoxy so the drug can't
come out on the other side we put gold
could be other things but gold we found
is quite good it's relatively safe and
and the idea is that if we simply apply
1 volt selectively to this wire we can
dissolve this cap this gold cap as soon
as we do our theory is all the drugs
should come out and we basically this
idea is that you could essentially have
a pharmacy on a chip that you could put
in multiple drugs that could be
delivered multiple times a day if you
want to someday you could put in micro
processors or biosensors
so you could get remote control or smart
systems well how do we go about doing
this well the next slide shows you
actually an example we've made these
they're actually the size of a dime
here's a dime and here's the chip what
you're looking at are two sides of both
sides of it on one side you see each of
these little dots and again we could
make these thoughts any size here we've
made them small but each dot could
contain a different drug or the same
drug at a different dose here's the
other side where you can see the wells
so you have a notes cathodes and
basically what we can do is selectively
trigger any one of these wells and when
we do the drug inside it should come
right out let me show you that let's do
a scanning electron micrograph of just
one well over time the next slide shows
you what one of these wells look like
scanning electron micrograph of one gold
cover but let's look at it as we apply
just one volt selectively to this one
and look at it over what happens in ten
seconds the next slide shows you that
what you see is as soon as you apply
this volt one voltage the gold cover
comes off and as soon as it does the
drug inside if there's no resistance
like it's more like in solution could
come right out and to illustrate that
let's do a release study as shown on the
next slide where what you see are
one drug now coming out multiple times
this is at one point five two point five
four point five five point five days
this is all arbitrary we could make them
come out whatever time we want by simply
triggering those individual Wells here
we've put simply one drug on but what if
we wanted to do multiple ones well the
next slide shows that where we've put
two drugs on and again we've done remote
by applying the one volt we make it one
come out of 25 hours another thirty five
another fifty another sixty in the long
run what we hope to achieve with this is
as I mentioned earlier you might have
systems where you could implant and have
you know do remote control like
telemetry like you to open up a garage
door to regulate this we're trying to
work on ways of doing that now you might
even incorporate biosensors onto these
to make a smart system with feedback
control there may be even systems we're
working on ones that you could swallow
where you wouldn't have to do remote
control where people might have to take
multiple drugs multiple times a day and
they would just come out when you wanted
them to again this is for the future not
yet for today now so far what I've done
in this talk is I've told you about what
we could do with existing materials and
make them better and do things you could
never do before but one of my other
concerns has been the materials
themselves you know I'm a chemical
engineer but I worked in the hot and
Children's Hospital in the 1970s for a
few years and one of the things I began
to observe was how do polymers find
their way into medicine being a chemical
engineer I would have liked to have
thought that it was people like myself
or material scientists or chemists that
played a role in bringing materials into
medicine but that's rarely been the case
almost always what's happened is that
clinicians or sometimes companies have
been trying to solve a medical problem
and what they've always done is they've
taken an off-the-shelf polymer that kind
of resembles the organ or tissue they're
trying to fix and they use it in a human
being so for example next slide this is
all true by the way what I'm going to
tell you if you look at the history of
how polymers have found their way into
medicine what have we seen well let me
just give you a couple examples back in
1967 at the National Institutes of
Health they were trying to design an
artificial heart this is actually
the origin of the artificial heart and
they they they were trying to figure out
what material they wanted and so the
clinicians there said well we want
something with a good flex life and they
thought about this and said what object
has a good flex life they said a ladies
girdle and they said what's it made out
of
it's poly ether urethane so they decided
to make the artificial heart out of the
poly ether urethane so what's happened
now that we're 32 years later
well actually the mechanical engineers
they've done a pretty good job at beats
the heartbeats long enough but if you
read various journals like even time or
Newsweek what do we see
the reason the artificial heart hasn't
worked very well is that very often when
the blood hits the surface of the
artificial heart it forms a clot and the
patient gets a stroke and they may die
and yet to me it didn't seem that
surprising that's something that was
designed to be a ladies girdle you know
it might not be the best thing to put in
the human body but but this so and and
that's still what's used this problem it
pervades all of medicine so dialysis
tubing was originally and still is
sausage casing vascular graft that's an
artificial blood vessel was a surgeon in
Texas going to a clothes store finding
well that what he could so well with and
I don't want to minimize these
approaches because it's they've enabled
progress to be made but there are also
problems as you know you can't make
small diameter blood vessels breast
implants actually I hope there's no no
lawyers here but um if if you look at
breast implants the origins of these one
was a lubricant and the other actually
was a mattress stuffing it's true I mean
you can kind of think of the logic that
they used
but but I mean it it is true I realize
it's funny but it actually is true I
mean that that's exactly what's happened
so what I started thinking about was
well maybe we can use a better approach
what if we take rather than
off-the-shelf materials what if we ask
the question what do we really want in a
biomaterial from an engineering
standpoint from biology standpoint from
a chemistry standpoint and then could we
synthesize them from first principles so
we picked an example and that example is
biodegradable polymers used in drug
delivery so the next slide shows you
what we were thinking about most
polymers that are used in drug delivery
dissolve like this show bulk erosion
start out like this becomes spongy and
fall apart and that can lead to bursts
of drug release which if you had a very
toxic drug like insulin or an
anti-cancer drug could be fatal so from
an engineering standpoint what would you
want next slide
so we said from an engineering
standpoint you'd much rather have this
that's the way of like a bar soap
dissolves and and that would prevent any
possibility of dumping the drug and so
without going through all the
engineering design analysis that we did
and we spent a lot of time on this we
came up with a polymer that we thought
would solve this problem next slide and
this is the one chemical structure I'll
show you so you might think here's a
very hydrophobic unit one that repels
water
here's another unit but just think about
it that we've got two units a and B and
what I'll show you on the next slide is
that by simply regulating the ratio of
that a to that B we can make these last
anywhere from like about 8% dissolved in
14 weeks if you use zero percent of one
of them whereas all of it will be gone
in two weeks if you use 79 percent and
so you can simply by dialing in the
ratio of A to B unit make these lasts
from almost any length of time you want
so if you could do that you have
tremendous control and you could begin
about thinking about applying these two
different diseases so let me give you an
example next slide about 12 years ago
Henry Bram a neurosurgeon came to see me
we're trying to find a better way to
cancer in particular a very bad form of
cancer brain cancer in its worst form
glioblastoma multiforme E which is
uniformly fatal and regardless of how
its treated the mean lifespan is less
than a year now the drug in addition to
these terrible statistics the drug you
used for brain cancer next slide B C and
U is a terrible drug causing terrible
side effects when you give it normally
it's given intravenously but it travels
throughout the whole body causes
terrible side effects too like the liver
kidney and spleen so our idea is shown
in the next slide local therapy could we
do this could we allow the neurosurgeon
like doctor bream to operate on the
patient but lying the surgical cavity
before he closes the patient with a
polymer containing BCNU now B C and you
normally as a lifetime in the body of 12
minutes but if you put in the polymer
it's protected it'll last as long as a
polymer less so what we wanted was a
degradable polymer that would not
accumulate in the brain a polymer that
dissolve like by the surface erosion so
it couldn't dump this really toxic drug
and finally from animal studies they
done at Hopkins our collaborators we
wanted to last for a month and you could
easily do that by adjusting those
monomer ratios now the polymer protects
the BCNU from degradation but the most
important thing is local therapy high
concentrations in the brain where you
want it to be and almost no
concentration in the rest of the body
where it caused these terrible side
effects so how I thought I would also
tell you how are these ideas greeted by
the scientific community so the next
slide i won't go through this in detail
but i put you know when you're a
professor as all the people speaking
today are generally have to write grants
usually in all of our cases this morning
probably two National Institutes of
Health and when you write these grants
they write back you know comments about
them from other scientists so I decided
I'd show you some of them and I entitled
this slide this approach will not work
because I simply pulled this out of
different grants without going into
detail every two years we've got a
different objection each time we would
solve it we'd get a different
Jaxson this probably all my colleagues
would have similar stories it's actually
the way science again scientists work
but point is that every two years you
get a different one and finally by 1996
we taken this from a concept we drew on
paper to a brand new treatment that was
actually approved by the FDA and
actually the only treatment as I will
show you in a few minutes that was
approved by the FDA for treating brain
cancer in the last 25 years but but this
is basically sort of what happens I'd
like to actually show you a picture - of
how this looks but if anybody is
squeamish and I mean this seriously
doesn't like the sight of blood don't
look at the next slide or - but but let
me just show you on the next slide what
the operation looks like you put little
wafers the size of a dime in the human
brain next slide there's about seven or
eight of them next slide and then you
close up the brain
I always show those slides very quickly
and the reason I do you know it's very
hard to get good advice on your talks
but a couple years ago my wife who's a
neuroscientist who got her PhD with Ann
Graybiel here came to one of my talks
and I asked her at the end this was a
talk to chemical engineers and I asked
her at the end of the talk I said well
what did you think of the talk she said
what was okay that was actually pretty
good praise from her but um she said it
was okay but she said those that
15-minute period where you had those two
slides on and you explained the whole
operation she said I don't know if you
noticed but all those chemical engineers
were turning green and looking at the
floor so I've always shown those slides
very quickly after that except that I
want to tell you a little bit of a
sequel to that which was that a couple
years ago I was asked to give a speech
actually at what's called the Princeton
conference where a lot of neurologists
and neurosurgeons go this was actually
is also a dinner speech and
and and and I showed those same two
slides and I went through them very
quickly and at the end of the talk
actually a number of the neurosurgeons
came up to me and they said you know
those two bloody slides you showed you
could have kept them on as long as you
wanted but they said those chemical
formulas so so I have learned that
depending on what audience I speak to I
keep different slides on different
lengths of time to show you a little bit
of the clinical data this is from what's
called the phase three trial final stage
clinical trial this was in Europe and
what you see is that at the end of a
year when the treated group 63 percent
of the patients are alive at the end of
the control group which are best ways of
treating brain tumors at the time
19 percent alive at the end of two years
31 percent in the treated group six
percent in the control group and again
our hope is this is just the tip of the
iceberg that this may at least four
tumors that are relatively localized you
might be able to have ways of doing
local therapy and in a broader sense
makes maybe people think of more
rational ways of designing polymers for
many many diseases I'd like to spend now
the last final minutes not just the use
of materials for treating drugs but for
actually delivering human cells to the
body let me motivate this with another
picture of a patient this child next
slide
who has liver failure and so he's
bloated like that because a liver with
all the edema next slide now the only
way a child like that can live is
someone else has to die and you give him
a transplant but the problem with that
justtake liver is last year in the
United States 30,000 patients died of
liver failure there are only enough
donors for 3,000 patients so many people
including that child unfortunately died
just can't get a donor how do you solve
that problem well B the way J Vacanti
who's my collaborator in a lot of these
studies Jay's a transplant to surgeon at
Mass General Hospital we came up with
this idea about 16 years
that may be what you could do is take
well maybe I should say it this way if
you take isolated dissociated cells and
inject them into the body not much
happens if you take those same cells put
them close enough together they're
actually smart they can actually reform
structures and group for example at
Berkeley is shown that you can take
mammary epithelial cells put them close
enough together they can actually form a
sand eye and make milk so our thinking
was couldn't we make polymer fibers
where the cell we could take any cell
type line them up on these polymer
fibers grow them in vitro and again a
lot of this involves the right kind of
polymer synthesis and design but grow
them up in vitro and form a new tissue
this is our strategy it allowed them to
recreate their structure outside the
body so let me give you a couple of
examples the next slide just shows you a
picture of what the polymer scaffolds
look like with liver cells so we have
very very we have to design these so
they have a very high surface area to
volume ratio you so you could put a lot
of cells on so I'll give you three
examples in terms of closing the talk
first one is cartilage there's over a
million operations each year where
people need new cartilage our idea is
someday what you'll be able to do is go
in with the minimally invasive procedure
in arthroscopy like say go into the year
we're actually even doing this on
patients now but your ear is all
cartilage take a few cells multiply them
outside the body which you can do
that'll solve the donor shortage problem
and on a scaffold that you could make in
any shape you want so let's say you
wanted to do plastic surgery on a person
some day and make a new tissue well we
have I'll show you an example on a nude
Mouse next slide here what we decided is
we want to redo this guy's skull we made
a scaffold like this put cartilage in it
and we did it on the next slide what
I'll show you is another nude mouse we
redid this cheek the next slide shows
you if you open these animals up what
the tissue looks like and it looks like
cartilage acts like Cardinals and so
forth but let me get to more practical
applications there are children who
don't have ears and Joe Upton one of our
collaborators want to make new ears for
patients so Linda Griffith one of my
former postdocs again now professor at
MIT next slide
made a scaffold in the form of a human
ear here is the scanning electron
micrograph
where you see the cell matrix and Chuck
Vacanti another collaborator actually
placed this on a rabbit next slide and
you see the human ear on the rabbit now
next slide now you might say well why do
you do Studies on animals
the reason we do Studies on animals is
because it we want to find out if it's
safe to do them on people and here's a
12 year old boy this 12 year old boy
though unlike other 12 year old boys
doesn't have a chest covering his heart
and he likes to play baseball like other
12 year old boys but if he were hit with
a baseball in the chest he could die
because he has no protection so what we
did is we fashioned a scaffold
using these polymer principles and dr.
McCarthy and my collaborator put a new
chest in them the next slide shows the
image of that showing his chest being
protected he's now 16 years old in fact
Businessweek had featured him last year
riding a skateboard and he's doing very
well so that's just an example our hope
is to do many more of these as we move
to the future next slide so that's one
example which we're even doing today a
beginning to do today on patients but
what about the future
well one area could be nerve
regeneration they're actually polymers
that we thought could be very
interesting because they conduct
electricity it's been shown that
electrical charges can stimulate
neuronal processes and even stimulate
regeneration of transected sciatic nerve
ends and we have found that an
electrically conducting polymer known as
poly pyro can have profound effects on
stimulating nerve regrowth at least in
vitro and we're beginning to see that in
vivo and so what we did this was done
work done by Prasad Shastri and
Christine Schmidt next slide is to take
a sciatic nerve model make a gap and and
do what we trying to call like a nerve
guide like say you severed your finger
could you have a guide where you'd put
the nerve endings from one side and to
the other and have them grow across a
distance and that's basically what was
done here but if you look at one of the
key things to look at next slide next
slide are the density of nerve fibers
and here each of these little circles is
a nerve fiber that we see on the poly
pyrole six weeks later to compare that
to regular nerve next slide looks quite
sim
and yet if you do a control polym or
even some of the ones that people have
explored as a nerve guide next slide you
don't see nearly the number of nerve
endings this is silicon here's poly
pyrrol so there's a huge difference
transmission electron microscope shows
similar data and and now of course the
key is to do electrophysiology studies
which we've been in the process of doing
with people at Children's Hospital to
really look at function again this is
much more to the future than it is today
but I think it's something that may
someday be possible which was kind of
what I'm trying to illustrate in the
talk but with that in mind let me return
to the present and still try to get
across I think some of the very exciting
things that can be done even with
technology that we've already developed
and the last example that I'd like to
give you concerns the fact that we've
actually as many things at MIT are
licensed these two companies and let the
companies work on them in different
indications we license some of this
technology to a company in San Diego and
they've been working on creating new
skin for burn victims so let me end this
talk with that example show you a
picture of a two year old boy on the
next slide
who's badly burned two year old child
but next slide using the principles I
just mentioned you can make a polymer
cell system this is a human dermal
fibroblasts from neonates and what you
can do on the next slide is layer that
over the child at the time of the burn
and on the next slide you see him three
months later
I'm sorry three weeks later and on the
next and last slide you see him six
months later next slide or slides off
this again was approved by the FDA in
1997 and basically again illustrates
what might be achieved by using these
kinds of approaches and it is my hope
that as we move to the future that what
I've talked to you about today are just
but a few examples of the things I hope
materials can do in terms of relieving
suffering and prolonging life thank you
very much
[Applause]
and our final speaker dr. David page
good morning I'm gonna we're gonna try
to keep some time for questions at the
end as I understand so I'm going to try
to be fairly brief here want to want to
share with you some ideas just plant in
your mind I know when many of you were
here at MIT biology was not yet a
required course and DNA was not the the
common subject that it is today but any
case I want to introduce you today to
the notion of DNA second concept
spelling differences and the third thing
a crit a method for finding critical
spelling differences so if that's all
work that's that's what I'm going to
summarize for you in the next few
minutes see if this works for me could I
have the first slide
this is sort of a cruel test but if I
could have the first slide please oh
well this is the second aspect of the
cruel test can you see it
no somehow too much light okay
too much ceiling light is that is it
visible now okay a little better okay
well as I understand it today brings
with it the third leg of the Triple
Crown and so I present to you Willie
shoemaker he's not going to be running
today but he and well Chamberlain agreed
to pose for this slide the point here is
that we human beings come in a great
variety of shapes and sizes how do we
come to be so spectacularly variable not
only in our outward appearances but also
in our disease susceptibilities and our
state of health is it is it purely bad
luck that some of us will get
Alzheimer's while others will not is it
purely bad luck that some have a heart
attack at a young age while others do
not
well if we could understand the causes
of disease at the most fundamental level
if we can understand why some of us are
at particular risk we would have
powerful new tools to bring to bear in
our search for cures and prevention and
we might even be able to customize our
own medical care that is we might even
know which disease or diseases each of
us is most in need of preventing well in
the last 40 years biology has undergone
it works biology has undergone a
transformation nothing short of a
revolution and that's why biology is now
a required course here we've come to
understand that the central player in
biology is DNA and I basically this
slide summarizes the now
required course so if but of course we
we do take a full semester to present
the material so I won't go into great
detail but basically let the central
idea that you've got it you've got a
blueprint in each of the ten trillion
cells that make up your body you've got
a blueprint this material called DNA and
somehow that information gets translated
ultimately into a series of proteins
this DNA makes RNA makes protein is
really the central dogma of the
revolution that's occurred in biology
now it turns out that each of us has 3
billion letters 3 billion letters of DNA
our instruction books contain 3 billion
letters and it turns out that any two
humans are virtually identical in the
instruction book 99.9% identical so as
you look around the room it is not
simply a matter that you are all MIT
alumni that makes you similar in fact
your DNA sequences are 99.9% identical
to that to those sequences of anyone
else on the planet but there are
differences these are spelling
differences so it turns out that this
the your DNA sequences are made up of
very simple alphabet they're only four
letters at least that's the way we
symbolize them AC G and T and here I
show for example a string of A's and c's
and g's and T's and an occasional
difference occasionally there's a
spelling difference that distinguishes
your DNA from that of your neighbor one
in a thousand there's basically a
spelling difference about one in a
thousand letters well multiply that by
three billion makes for three million
differences between any two people so
now you can look at your neighbors even
though they are also MIT alumni and
recognize your individuality at the
level of your DNA sequence except of
course if you're an identical twin
that's a special case you have the same
DNA sequences
well in the last 10 or 20 years Gilman
genetics the field of human genetics has
developed general methods for finding
the spelling differences that are
critical to certain diseases I'll just
give you the example here of cystic
fibrosis a devastating disease of
childhood that I'm sure that many of you
have had direct or indirect contact with
now I'd like you to study this slide in
great detail over here is a long string
of A's and c's and g's and T's this is
part of that three billion letter text
that each of you has and it turns out
there's a particular three letters that
are blown up over here CT T well it
turns out that if you're missing those
three letters CT T you will develop
cystic fibrosis if you have those three
letters you won't get cystic fibrosis
and so it's those three letters the rest
of the text can be perfect but if those
three letters are missing you will
develop cystic fibrosis now I want to
give you sort of give you a sense of the
scale of the issue here and I'm going to
make an analogy between all of our DNA
sequences and the planet I want to give
you a sense of what it means to homed in
on on those three missing letters so
again our field has developed over the
last two decades a powerful means of
homing in on the critical spelling
differences the planet here would be
analogous to the three billion letters
of DNA that are found in each of our
cells now we're going to move in from
the three billion letter level to the 30
million letter level it turns out will
now be on the appropriate chromosome we
will have found the chromosome on which
the cystic fibrosis defect lies we'll
move in now to the three million letter
level we can see the shoreline of Lake
Michigan coming into view now we'll move
down to the level of a
about 30,000 letters the marina
is coming into view it turns out we're
now within the Cystic what is called the
cystic fibrosis gene we haven't yet
found the critical spelling error within
it but we're in the right we're in the
right functional unit and finally to get
down to the level of the above the of
the critical spelling error it's
analogous to seeing the hairs on the
back of a hand of somebody who's sitting
on a bench next to that marina well the
point is that this is now a routine
matter in human genetics to start with
the planet to start with all of our
three billion letters and to end up at
the end of what is increasingly a short
doable thesis project for a PhD student
to end up with knowledge of the critical
spelling error underlying one or another
human disease so they're a growing
number of common diseases for which
certain spelling differences are known
to cause to be predisposing or causative
breast cancer colon cancer heart disease
alzheimer's i could go on and on and on
the hard part is finding the spelling -
I'd said it's become easy but it's still
you know it requires some effort to find
the spelling differences underlying a
disease in the first place once you're
confident that that spelling difference
is a critical predictor of a particular
disease or even when you suspect that
that spelling difference might be a good
predictor then it is relatively trivial
and will undoubtedly become irresistibly
cheap to test lots of people for that
spelling difference most children with
cystic fibrosis have precisely the same
spelling error so you could you could
envision testing everyone for that or
other spelling errors and that's genetic
testing testing individuals for critical
spelling differences in their DNA
well I've mentioned already you have 10
trillion cells in your body and they all
each of the 10 trillion cells in your
body contains the complete blueprint so
if you could spare just a few cells
maybe on the way out will be collecting
sample if you could spare a few cells
maybe maybe the skin cells that you left
behind on your napkin at breakfast that
would be just that would be perfectly
sufficient will prepare DNA and get the
test results back to you by by the end
of this alumni gathering what would you
most like to know would you like to know
if you are among the 60 people in this
room one in 20 who are carriers for the
cystic fibrosis spelling error the
omission of those three letters perhaps
you would like to know whether you're
one of the 200 people in this room who
are three times as likely as the rest to
develop Alzheimer's disease well perhaps
you'd like to know whether you are among
the ten people in this room who have a
particular spelling error that put them
at a 90 percent risk of developing colon
cancer well we could tremendously
accelerate the process of finding the
causes of disease if we had on file
detailed satellite photos down to this
level of detail showing not just the
back of the hand on a person on Lake
Michigan Shores but if everything on the
entire planet if we had on file the
entire repertoire of DNA in our cells
think of what we might do if we had
absolutely comprehensive Maps well that
is exactly what the human genome project
is about to make those maps available
for the study of all human diseases now
the human genome project is a federally
funded effort begun in 1990 with the
goal of coming to closure in just in
just five or six years by night by 2005
the goal of the human genome project is
to make those maps available for the
study of all human diseases I just want
to give you a 30-second summary of where
we are today in the human genome project
well turns out here's the ultimate
here's our ultimate goal to know the
complete string of A's and c's and g's
and t's the whole three billion letter
text well and there were a number of
intermediate stages through which the
whole field understood it had to pass it
turns out we have now passed all the
intermediate checkpoints in fact the
first complete so-called
map of a human chromosome was of the Y
chromosome and it was completed here at
MIT in 1992
three years later also here at MIT at
the genome Center there would be
completed physical maps that were
completed physical maps of all you all
of the human chromosomes so it is now
time to get on basically all these
intermediate stages have now been
reached it's time to get on now with the
actual determination of the string of
agencies and G's and T's for the
entirety of the human genome the
ultimate map and the tools to make that
possible and in fact the effort is
beginning those tools are being
assembled and the effort is beginning to
a very large degree here at the MIT
genome Center and as well as several
centers elsewhere around the world I
think it's very likely that we will in
fact have a rough draft of the text that
is a ninety maybe a 99% accurate draft
of the text within twelve to eighteen
months and in all likelihood we will
have a very we will have a reference
grade text available in three years time
that's going to be an extraordinarily
powerful tool that will dramatically
accelerate the revolution in human
biology now you can already appreciate
that there during that there are dangers
that lurk ahead as well we're becoming
good fast even at discovering the causes
of disease but there tends to be a lag
to development of rational therapies
therapies that are based on our
knowledge of the cause
disease and in the interim when we
diagnose predisposition to disease but
cannot cure that information if misused
could affect one's access to employment
education insurance and so on and so at
the same time
that we recognize the extraordinary
potential this information we also
recognize that we've got to collect and
safeguard this potentially toxic
knowledge of our own genes and actually
this afternoon at 3:00 I'll be chairing
a panel discussion where we're going to
try to explore some of the ethical side
of human genetic information but in the
last few minutes here I'd like to turn
to quite a different topic
well actually it has a lot to do with
human variation maybe it's the most
fundamental aspect of human variation
well there's one there's one aspect of
human variation that I would claim that
we have all been in studying intensely
since childhood one of the oldest
questions in biology boys and girls men
and women well it's been obvious that
the members of our species come in two
fundamental forms male and female for a
long time although perhaps at the time
when some of you were attending MIT that
wasn't so obvious
okay well it's actually a lot more
obvious now at MIT people have been
wondering about how you make boys and
how you make girls what determines
whether the you know what's the first
question that any any that anybody asks
a new parent is it a boy is it a girl
people have been wondering about what
happens before the baby is born to
determine whether it develops as a boy
or a girl
well Aristotle was Aristotle was perhaps
the first developmental biologist he
thought that the sex of an embryo the
sex of a baby was determined by the
level of excitement of the father during
sexual intercourse Aristotle thought
that the hotter the action the greater
the chance that one would have a I never
have to complete that sentence well in
the 1890s thinking was still focused
even as late as the 1890s people were
thinking about factors in the
environment they weren't they certainly
weren't thinking about genes the concept
of genes didn't even appear until this
century so in the 1890s people were
still thinking about environment the
most widely accepted view in the 1890s
was that the mother's diet during
pregnancy determined the sex of the
embryo I've always wondered how they
reconciled the occurrence of boy and
girl twins there were other seriously
debated theories that focused on the
state of war peace the phases of the
Moon this is actually still widely
believed just read the National Enquirer
economic fortunes there are a zillion
theories I think any basically in my
experience virtually everyone has their
own theory as to the true cause of
whether a baby is born a boy or a girl
but at least a tap for biologists things
in for human biologists things clarified
tremendously in ninth in the year
nineteen
59 in 1959 it became clear that whether
a baby was born as a boy or a girl
depended on one chunk of DNA and that
chunk of DNA is the Y chromosome
turns out that most of the chunks of DNA
that we all carry these chunks are
called chromosomes most of the chunks
are absolutely identical between our are
identical between males and females but
there's one chunk of DNA that is found
in males and not found in females and
that is the Y chromosome these are this
is the whole collection of these DNA
chunks which we routinely call
chromosomes and the one with the red
circle around it is found in men who
have whose sex chromosomes are an X plus
a Y as opposed to an females there are
two x chromosomes and we've come to
understand that whether an embryo
develops as a as a male or a female
depends very simply on if the Y is
present in the embryo that embryo will
develop testes and as a male if the
embryo does not carry a Y chromosome the
embryo will develop ovaries and as a
female well that's sort of what we
understood in 1959 I want to fast
forward now to the present and we now
are coming close to understanding the
complete text of the Y chromosome and
what I want to suggest is that probably
by the end of this year or the latest by
the beginning of next year we will know
all of the spelling differences that
distinguish boys and girls that will be
an interesting text to decipher let me
tell you what we know about that text
already this is actually this was the
thesis work of an MIT graduate student
Bruce lawn defended his thesis about a
year and a half ago and what he came up
with was a gene map of the human Y
chromosome
it turns out that we can recognize you
know ice before a few minutes ago we
were homing in on the cystic fibrosis
gene and a spelling error within it well
it turns out these are a series of genes
that are found along the length of the Y
chromosome well talk about spelling
differences it turns out that it's not
even the entirety of the Y chromosome
that determines whether an embryo
develops as a male or a female it's
actually just one tiny bit of the Y
chromosome that makes the difference
it's actually just one gene over here
called sry so if you carry that one if
you as an embryo carry that one gene you
will develop testes and as a male if you
don't carry that gene you will develop
ovaries and as a female and to return to
the concept of spelling differences if
you actually within this gene which is
of course composed of a's and c's and
g's and tees that simple
that simple alphabet that i described to
you if you carry this gene but if you
have one misspelled letter you will
develop as a female not as a male so
ultimately the difference between
developing as a male or a female can
come down to one spelling change within
our 3 billion letter text that's the
kind of precision with which we can now
understand human development and human
variation and I would argue that's in
fact it's because of that sort of
precision that we now require that all
of our that all of your future alumni
study this subject so we've got this one
gene that determines whether you develop
as a male or female well in the last few
years we've come to understand some
other roles of the Y chromosome
infertility infertility is an
extraordinarily common problem it's
thought that about 10% of American
couples are
who attempt to have children are unable
to and if we went back a couple of
decades it was thought that virtually
all infertility the finger was usually
pointed at the wife well turns out about
half of infertility traces to the man
and what we found in the last few years
is that the Y chromosome is a frequent
site of misspellings that result in
infertility in fact we've now come to
understand that sort of going back to
this gene map that I was just showing
you it turns out there are three
different regions of the Y chromosome
one here one here one here if a man is
missing oh and notice remember where the
sex determining gene is over here so
this part of the Y can be perfectly
intact so that the embryo develops
testes and as a male a boy emerges grows
up but as an adult he might be unable to
make sperm and what we found is that
many men who were unable to make sperm
are unable to do so because they're
actually missing either this piece of
the Y or they're missing this piece of
the warning so we've come to understand
another a second aspect of the Y's role
in contributing to the differences
between the ultimate differences between
men and women
I think I'm since we're running short on
time I think I'm going to stop at that
point and just remind you that hopefully
by the end of the year by the beginning
of the next the Wike we'll know the
complete text the complete sequence of
agencies and GS and T's of the Y
chromosome in a sense at that point we
will know all the genes all the
Spelling's that distinguish the male
from the female and with the
increasingly co-ed complexion of the MIT
student body I think you'll agree with
me that
will be an interesting text to decipher
over the next year's and I'll close
there thank you
while our three speakers are coming up
and being seated on the stage here to
handle a few questions I want to tell
you two things one is that I was once
thumbing through Dave pages resume and
discovered that he had an honorary
degree conferred on him by Swarthmore
now that is a wonderful honor but
frankly many of our great faculty have
honorary degrees his was awarded while
he was an assistant professor and the
second story I wanted to tell you as I
was listening to our first two speakers
to Martha and then to Bob Langer there's
a true and very wonderful story that
ties together MIT its effect on
plasticity of the brain and delivery of
insulin and so forth our late great
president Jerry Wiesner used to tell the
following true story as you all know he
suffered a very debilitating stroke
later in his life and he was a diabetic
and Jerry woke up on the hospital gurney
with no idea what had happened to him
but knowing he desperately needed to
have some orange juice so he decided
that he would try to tell all these
nurses and doctors running around that
he needed orange juice but the only word
he could say was education so he said I
was lying there yelling education and
suddenly I realized what a lifetime at
MIT does to you we have a few questions
that have already been passed up from
the audience and more will be coming we
obviously can't handle all of them but
let me begin with one that I think is
very interesting and I'd ask for very
brief responses gets to the heart of
things would each of you comment on the
interaction between research and
teaching in your work David you want to
start that in teaching and research
actually I would say that for me the
interaction is
has worked very much in both directions
there were branches there were branches
of develop biology that I did not know
well when I arrived at MIT but which
it's actually there's a whole area of
developmental biology so I had
relatively little experience in when I
arrived at MIT I was called upon to do
some teaching and developmental biology
I've since come to regard myself
eventually as a developmental biologist
and so it's not just the interaction
with students but it's actually the the
new fields that teaching explores meet
that the teaching forces me to discover
that lead to my own professional
redefinition
well I think well there are two things
one is that you yourself and every
teacher will say this never really learn
anything until you have to teach it
there's nothing like a group of students
who know they're smart to to make sure
that the teacher knows his or her stuff
and then the second thing is that as a
scientist it's the students who not only
participate in the labs and do some of
the experiments with their own hands but
they're the ones who notice things
because they're fresh that those of us
who have been at it for a long time very
frequently miss we go in with
preconceived notions and the people who
come in from different backgrounds point
things out to us that we would never
have learned well I think what the last
two speakers said I would only add to I
mean I agree with both of those comments
and I'll just maybe make two additional
points one you know in some of the
classes we teach today we actually use
some of the modern research as an
examples so we teach courses for example
in engineering and biotechnology and
also an integrated chemical engineering
where some of the material I just used
today we make central to the class and I
think students really enjoy that because
it's
you know more on the cutting edge I
think the second point I would make is
that you know one of the things of
course that we all do is spend a lot of
time training graduate students and in
that way you see the research and a
teaching intersect because certainly one
of our objectives is to train graduate
students to be the leaders of the future
here's one addressed to Martha it's very
general but I think just sort of some
headline level comments would be very
interesting to the audience how close
are we to understanding memory we
actually do understand some forms of
memory already all right we can tell you
how a nerve cell why a nerve cell
responds differently to a stimulus that
it's gotten a lot of before down to the
level of what molecules change now
the catch is we can explain that in the
terms of what happened in terms of what
happens for five minutes 20 minutes we
can't tell you why those changes are
prolonged for hours or days in some
regions of the brain on a broader level
we know what regions of the brain are
not involved in memory there's still a
tremendous amount of debate about how
many regions of the brain are actually
involved in memory and so I think
conservatively to put a number on it
we're not going to truly understand
memory for probably another 30 years
we'll understand the molecular players
but we're not going to understand how
they all work together to make the
system work but it's coming very close
imaging techniques where you can
actually look at humans who are learning
and remembering things combined with the
ability to do similar Studies on animals
where you can go in and manipulate or
are improving or
understanding monthly thank you the next
question I'm going to use a chairs
prerogative and answer myself although
if my colleagues disagree with me they
can would more money spent at the basic
research level in universities help to
reduce the huge amount of money we spend
annually in the USA on health care about
1.5 trillion dollars the answer is yes
and and seriously there there are
actually some rather sophisticated
economic studies that show precisely
that that there is a deep correlation
between the advancement of basic
knowledge and life science and the
prolongation of life and quality of
health and ultimately cutting down on
some of the costs next question I guess
for Dave how soon will it be practical
to get my own complete three billion
letter gene map and compare it with
others statistical samples correlate it
with others and so forth okay so how
soon can you know all of your owns have
a have a little barcode of all your own
spelling differences that should it's
clear the technology will be in place
the spelling differences will be
catalogued to make that very feasible
within ten years I think the big
question a big question lurking beyond
that will be who's going to help you
interpret it and I think you'll get into
some aspect that's this afternoon's
discussion if anyone the next one really
sort of aimed at Bob but I think that
all three of you will have some
interesting input what are the prospects
for neuro therapeutics neuroengineering
broadly speaking development of new
field of neuro technology I'm not sure
I'm the best
person to address that you have maybe
but I but I mean I think that certainly
in the but in the areas that I talked
about I guess the hope would be new
treatments for example based on tissue
engineering for Parkinson's disease
there's some work going on in that
really any type of cell transplantation
approach the same type of thing we
talked about for nerves I think in the
drug delivery area it's it's a question
of you know drug delivery can help but I
think it's it's finding the right drugs
as well so we've already picked the
example of brain cancer and I think that
that's certainly an area where more may
go on but I you know I think it they can
really aid in any area if one is able to
find better and better drugs thank you
any other of you wish to comment I just
like to say that that many people have
great hopes for for slow-releasing
polymers when it comes to trying to
remedy some of the diseases and
dysfunctions of the nervous system
because they're you you basically have
to release within millimeters of potent
chemicals that you couldn't release
throughout the brain it would cause
convulsions all kinds of complications
and we are getting very very good at
implanting things in in brain regions
and so this kind of technology that that
produces that allows you to restrict
things is going to be tremendously
potent as we learn more of where we have
to put things and what we have to put in
Thank You Martha can continuing
amenities joy a question I'm sure
everybody wants to know a little bit
about I'm kind of combining two of them
at what age do human brains become less
developmentally plastic is it different
for different kinds of stimuli visual
audio and so forth and then there was a
second question that
really ask what general conclusions we
should be drawing for education and
raising of young children from your last
what I'll save it but that so yeah that
the difficulty is that different neural
systems mature and lose plasticity at
different rates and some of these
interact so you know the nervous system
isn't just a nice linear array their
feedback systems and so one has to first
understand what's the rate-limiting
pathway for a change in plasticity
different for humans different pathways
mature at vastly different rates newborn
the somatosensory pathway is supremely
tuned and in fact contact is
exceptionally important for young
children the auditory system is still
tuning and the visual system even though
the peripheral apparatus is working fine
the central nervous system still has a
tremendous amount of tuning so these
these problems with squint and
strabismus that I was talking about you
have to correct them within three within
the first three years of life to not
have any impairment and it varies from
individual to individual there are
individual differences and yet other
auditory pathways retain considerable
plasticity at some levels later I gave
you the example of the American sign
language that is pretty solid data
because they can do it on normal
developing children and and you can show
that that there really is a discrete
cutoff around four years of age for
these massive brain changes that are
associated with with using motion and
vision in a language context and then to
the last question I think there are
tremendous implications of this
developmental plasticity for how we deal
with our children as a society I I it's
it's I think one of the most important
things that biologists working in this
area can do now and that is to convince
people that
the need to have good early education
stimulating environments for young
children not at five when we classically
start it but actually early as young as
they can spend time away from their
mothers it's a just a historical
accident that we start education formal
education at five and there are lots of
longitudinal studies that say it should
be done earlier but unfortunately there
are political reasons why that money
doesn't want to be spent in that way it
would probably save us a tremendous
amount of money in the later years of
life there are is there are just there's
a lot of work children are highly
plastic they're capable of absorbing
tremendous amounts of information from
toddlerhood on wood they learn a lot
from other other children and from
dealing with a range of different kinds
of different adults in different
situations and we should be paying a lot
more attention to early education into
child care
switching gears and tossing a question
to Professor Paige that even I know
enough about to know really is loaded
but it's a great story what role do
private companies like PerkinElmer can't
quite read all these but it says human
genome I think we know we're talking
about what role do private companies
have in the sequencing of the human
genome and are they competitive or
collaborative all right
that is okay that's a very hot life
question actually always just yesterday
I spent the day at NIH reviewing grants
and it's always the topic in the in the
background it turns out the human genome
project has you know as I said it it
started as a federally funded effort
officially in 1990 it has succeeded
wildly it's it's been ahead of schedule
under budget and of course one of the
there were really two motivations to
sort of selling points for the human
genome project early on first it had
great promise of improving human health
and I think that will be realized and
secondly it was realized that
biotechnology was an area in which the
United States is preeminent and that
pushing the Human Genome Project would
help maintain that preeminence of US
industry well that has come to pass with
such lightning speed that now genome
science is a booming area in the private
sector and in fact the power of this of
the information the power of knowing the
text the three billion letter text is so
widely appreciated that private
investors would like to have a look at
that information six months before it
becomes publicly available don't this is
perfectly serious
and and so there is a race on now
I mean it to be honest there is a race
on between the publicly funded
sequencing the human genome and
privately funded sequencing of the human
genome recognizing the extraordinary
power and the extraordinary intellectual
property that resides within that
sequence there is hopes that this that
this effort will be collaborative I
think it will be like all of science has
always been that is a strange mixture of
collaboration and competition that will
drive the field forward but it's going
to be an extraordinary the next 12 to 24
months will be extraordinary thank you
Bob Langer who is working on growing
whole organs using the polymer technique
sort of what's a stage when is it going
to be ready to go well there are a
variety of groups working on on areas
like this there's work going on at
Children's Hospital with some of our
collaborators led by Tony Atala a
urologist trying to make a bladder there
are there is research going on where
people are trying to make a liver Linda
Griffith one of my former postdocs now
professor at MIT has been working on
that I'd also add that there are
companies like there's a local company
called Searcy biomedical that's working
on a liver as what's called the bridge
to transplant I mentioned that picture
showed that picture of the small child
who was dying while awaiting a liver
transplant and right now they're in the
final stages of clinical trials using
systems that could keep a patient like
that alive for several weeks while
awaiting for a transplant
Martha is there an implication about the
incidence of attention deficit disorder
to be inferred from the research on
developmental plasticity of the brain
for example does excessive stimulation
at an early age result in a later
inability to discriminate among
stimulatory inputs they're there
unfortunately we don't understand
the pathway is involved in attentional
deficit disorder
we don't it's a it's a disorder that we
infer is associated with the transmitter
dopamine because you can treat it but
pharmacologically altering the
dopaminergic system but like many things
in the brain we don't understand really
why that works or why it takes why it
occurs in the timescale it does and
there are neurological diseases and
disorders that have to do with not
trimming these exuberant projections I
was talking about for example many
people believe that some aspects of
autism are associated with it so if you
don't trim them appropriately that's not
good but it's also becoming quite clear
that a lot of this plasticity this
example of the owls that can actually
achieve this adjustment later in life if
they are asked to do it early on that is
probably the result of keeping some
exuberant projections but keeping them
suppressed until you need to use them so
it's a balance of both this excitatory
Drive and selective use of inhibitory
systems and I didn't talk about them an
attentional deficit deficit disorder has
all the attributes of a failure to use
inhibition appropriately we have no idea
of how many different areas of the brain
are involved when that goes wrong and it
may well be that attentional deficit
disorder defined as a syndrome it may
not be that it's the same in all people
I'm going to give two questions to David
the first which is headline stuff at the
moment Dali the clone has aged I can't
quite read it but as we all know she
appears to be aging much more rapidly
because she would possibly because she
was cloned with
mature genes what do you think is the
impact of this knowledge and secondly
while we're talking about these things
how is gene therapy executed held
obviously the genes in every cell can't
be changed so the card says a little bit
about technology a little bit about the
recent dalai aging okay so first let me
deal with with dali it's actually our
now missing panel member Bob Weinberg
had actually commented extensively on
this in the press in the last week and
Bob correctly pointed out that the
though there has been extraordinary
press attention to the what looks to be
the aging of the DNA chunks the aging of
the chromosomes in dolly the present
evidence the present scientific evidence
is a mere shred of evidence and it
really seems far too it's far too early
to draw any conclusions about whether
Dolly's chromosomes really show signs of
aging but I think that the attention
drawn to this shred of evidence tells us
more about the extraordinary public
interest in the question than it
actually does about the scientific data
that's available at the moment with
regard to how gene therapy is done I
think its first put it in broad
perspective gene therapy is not yet a
reality no one has been cured of a
disease by gene therapy as yet but the
the question was was a very astute one
that is if you've got these ten trillion
cells and they've all got the same you
know they've all carrying the blueprint
how are you going to go about how do you
travel from from each of these cells how
do you travel among all ten trillion
correcting the spelling error well it
turns out that many of the spelling
errors have consequence only in a
particular part of the body so in the
case of cystic fibrosis for instance
many of the most devastating
complications of cystic fibrosis
involved
the lining of the airways to the lung
they get clogged and so in in the case
of cystic fibrosis for example there is
no gene therapy at present but it is
being attempted and the attempt is being
made to deliver the good gene that
missed the properly spelled gene to
deliver it directly to the Airways of
the lung and in that case you've all had
you've all had foreign invasions of the
airways to your alarm you've had colds
and in fact people who are developing
gene therapies for cystic fibrosis are
actually trying to piggyback the good
gene on the properly spelled gene on the
back of the bugs that cause colds so
that's that's a that's an attempt to
harness a vehicle that's appropriate to
the target and there are many other
similar stories I'm going to give a
couple of questions for sort of a quick
reaction to Bob Langer first question
says might a member of the class of 1967
lived to see his arthritic knee
cartilage is replaceable and the second
is also a serious personal question
wanting to know about how one would go
about getting information about new uses
of artificial skin in this case a person
has had skin removed from one part of
his or her body to repair another and
wants to know sort of where that stands
well I guess the answer to the first
question is I hope so but you know it's
hard to really predict when medicines
are going to be available or when new
therapies are going to be available and
the last thing that people like myself
who work in these areas want to do is
create false hope I think that that
there was very active work going on at
their clinical trials ongoing
in different situations but when but but
I think the very key thing is just
because those are their doing it doesn't
necessarily mean it will work and my
hope is that within 10 years we'll we'll
know you know things either will be
available or we'll know some good
answers to it but you really can't be
sure about the timing
the second issue about the skin you know
there are several companies making new
skin and probably the best thing to do
is to call one of them there's a company
that that I mentioned doing the skin
work that is based on some of our work
is a vast issue Sciences in La Jolla
California there's another local company
called organogenesis and Canton
Massachusetts and there's a company
called Genzyme tissue repair in
Cambridge and each of them have
different types of approaches for making
skin probably the best thing to do is to
contact you know people in those
companies I would think you now Martha
because you're about to become a new
member of the MIT faculty our alumni and
alumni are being very gentle and not
asking hard questions today are you
ready please define consciousness and
tell us what we know about it
this is very unfair I I don't think
neuroscientists have any better
definition of consciousness than poets
actually you know we still debate you
know we're down the phylogenetic line
consciousness starts it clearly involves
the cerebral cortex but the cerebral
cortex requires activating things from
the brainstem to achieve it so it's it
is a state in which the cortex has a
certain pattern of electrical activity
however that's not the defining factor
because in many times in a sleeping
brain you can have similar patterns of
activity and are you conscious when
you're dreaming so we don't have we do I
have been at meetings of neurobiologists
actually planning meetings for the NIH
where we spent in this panel of experts
an hour and a half trying to come up
with guidelines for studying and
defining consciousness there isn't a
good answer yet are there any poets who
would like to come David another sort of
question like that that we all think and
try to understand since twins are born
with the same genetic code what happens
at the cellular and molecular level that
makes them different even if the
environmental did I can't quite read
that but they're asking really about the
environmental differences that cause
twins to grow up being very different
people and do we know anything about
what occurs down at the cellular
molecular level you worry about that
feeds into that understanding well I'm
going to I think I'm going to twist my
answer around a bit I think that's an
invitation to speak to the degree to
which we are we are
simple readout of our genes I mean I did
as I mentioned identical twins have the
same have have no have no spelling
differences between them they have the
same instruction book I think it's it's
very popular these days our media are
full of stories about the gauging the
Happiness gene the gene for anxiety
there's a an idea is is a field that we
are just our genes and nothing more I
think nothing could be further from the
truth
we actually it will take decades it will
take hundreds of years it will take
forever to figure out where the actions
of our genes stop and where the actions
of our parents and our environments and
such begin and where they stop and so
it's a it's a perfectly framed question
actually identical twins are in fact the
the context that human geneticists most
like to examine because the huge
difference is that we know can arise
between identical twins we suspect are a
reflection of the complexity of the of
the environments and even though we say
identical twins they may grow up in the
same household in the with the same
parents their experiences are never
exactly the same but it really brings me
around to this this very fundamental
question what are the limits of genetic
determinism and I think we don't know
them but I think they're very frequently
overstated yes please there are
beginning to be some some very
intriguing studies now of genetic
monozygotic twins identical twins who
have different behaviors and there was
one very interesting study of
twins afflicted with Tourette syndrome
which has a genetic component it's a
it's a two motor disorder and it has
various degrees of severity some people
function quite normally and some are
very severely afflicted they have
personality disorders and ticks and
things and there were a set of imaging
studies this functional magnetic
resonance imaging studies done was
actually it was a different type of
imaging but they were looking at the
distribution of a certain population of
receptors in regions of the brain that
control these tics regions called the
the caudate nucleus part of the basal
ganglia and they had a set of a panel of
neurologists evaluate the severity of
the disease in these twins and then
completely independently they imaged
them and they correlated quite precisely
the distribution of some receptors in
the caudate nucleus with the severity of
the disease these are they were raised
in the same home using - I got twins
raised in the same home and and there
were organic differences in their brain
that showed up in behavior that
correlated that very closely
so clearly it wasn't just the genes in
that case David you've mentioned the
press on the gay gene as you were
answering that question there is a
specific question here asking if there
are correlations between the gene
alphabet and homosexuality I knew that
question had to come that's why I I was
hoping that perhaps I'd dealt with it in
my previous answer but I guess I I
should have known better this is
actually the question that I'm most
frequently asked by both my parents and
my in-laws when they when we the topic
of my work comes up so right to what
degree is sexual preference encoded in
our DNA Spelling's the answers are far
from in the first suggestive evidence
appeared in 1995 I believe
there is there is reasonably strong
evidence though controversial there is
reasonably strong evidence that that
homosexuality in men is at least
partially predisposed to by spelling
differences but that evidence remains
very controversial it's not clear how
significant a factor it is and even if
it is a factor it leaves open the
question of the role of environment so I
guess where I'll end up is if I had to
bet today I would I would say yes there
probably are genetic predisposes to to
sexual preference but the story is very
very far from complete thank you I'm
going to end by giving everybody an
opportunity if they wish each of you an
opportunity to comment on this rather
general and interesting question do you
think that the enhancement of life and
treatment of disease in the future will
primarily come from natural substances
artificially generated drugs or DNA
technologies they care to comment on
that
by the way we have some faculty here
have very strong views on this but maybe
it's not among these three engineers
I'd say the last two I think and I think
that they may work together I think you
know the artificially Jen I think DNA
work gives you targets and certainly
genetic engineering has been a powerful
tool as a method for generating new
drugs but and and again different types
of approaches that people are using for
drug design I think you know are getting
more advanced and I think we'll see more
and more drugs made that way as well I'm
no expert in this but from what I read a
lot of companies have teens that go out
particularly into the rain forest
because they think these things are
going to disappear and they dig up soil
bacteria or organisms that live in the
high canopy or they go down to the
depths of the ocean they pull things out
of hot springs to find natural
substances that they can then use on
tissue and figure out what about those
molecules is making them effective so I
think the answer is all of the above I
mean one of the one of the molecules
that I know many of you will appreciate
that has made DNA technology possible is
an enzyme that can function at that that
isn't destroyed at very high
temperatures and it comes from a
bacteria that is a hot spring I mean
this is he should be answering that that
that is is adapted to live in
tremendously hot places so it can it
needs these enzymes that can function
I'm going to answer the question in sort
of two parts I think it's worthwhile
remembering what the major causes of
disease were in this country earlier in
this century those were
Infectious Diseases that remains the
case for the majority of people in the
world so if we actually look beyond our
own borders I think the question as to
what will improve human health and
well-being it will actually be a
combination of economic development
improvement of sanitation and focused
battles against the parasites and
infectious agents that still plague the
majority of our species within our own
more highly developed societies I
suspect that the most important
improvements to health and well-being
will actually come from continued
changes in ongoing changes in human
behavior smoking and then from what what
I was vaguely alluding to in my
presentation that is the ability to
customise preventative health care based
on knowledge of our predispositions
thank you as we end here I just wanted
to point out that inevitably I have had
to bypass a large number of
extraordinarily good questions mostly
for three reasons one several of the
points were actually touched on as our
panelists answered other questions too
there were a large number which clearly
were aimed at Bob Weinberg's talk and
unfortunately as we knew in advance Bob
would not be able to be with us for the
Q&A and three there are some remarkably
interesting questions that are going to
fit precisely into the afternoon session
that David point mentioned dealing with
some of the ethical and moral issues
that we now are going to be confronting
running all the way from some of the
genetic technology based questions to
things like bias of medical research
toward males in the United States and so
forth so it's gonna be a lot of food for
thought and I hope that all of you one
way or another
we'll get a chance to address your
questions to these or other experts as
the day progresses we are now going to
break up in just a moment and move as
quickly and efficiently as possible
to the Johnson Athletic Center where we
will reconvene for Technology Day
luncheon but please join me in welcoming
Martha to the MIT faculty into thanking
all three of our colleagues